foreign
uh certainly um would you like to let me
know where we'd reached before the sound
gave out
so shall i go right back to the start of
the introduction
okay that's all right i'm going to put
the uh headset on hope that this doesn't
blow the whole system
can you hear me
well good morning everybody and welcome
to this labour overview and scrutiny
committee i'm alex councillor alastair
mccraw and i'm chairing the meeting
today
may i first of all remind you of some
domestic arrangements please ensure that
microphones are turned off when not in
use and that you do not interrupt other
speakers
but if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure that mobile phones are
either turned to silent or switched off
remember the chat function is only to
indicate that you wish to speak you also
have the option of the hand function on
the top bar
and please don't post any comments or
questions any messages in the chat panel
can be viewed by people watching the
live broadcast
i'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing
the whole meeting
confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you're also consenting to being recorded
by the council and the possible use of
those images and sound recordings for
webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the press are not lawfully excluded
so now come to introductions i will now
ask the governance officer to carry out
the introductions for today
thank you chair um the cabinet members
at
present at the meeting this morning
are
um
council ward the leader and cabinet
member for finance
councillor osborne cabinet member for
housing and councilman vesey cabinet
member for environment
we also have offices attending today and
we have our chief executive attending
the assistant director for law and
governance and monitoring officer
assistant director corporate resources
assistant director for environment and
commercial partnerships assistant
director for housing
corporate manager financial services
commissioning and procurement corporate
manager for waste recycling and fleet
senior finance business partner
assistant manager
finance accountant and also we have
richard walker
parking partnership group manager north
essec parking partnership
thank you chair
thank you very much i appear to have
lost um
the agenda which i had so conveniently
on a screen in front of me has
disappeared
so let's see if we can get that back
right having got that back can i now
move to the agenda please
please note there are no minutes on the
agenda of today's meeting the last uh
baber overview and scrutiny committee
meeting was held in june 2020 since then
we've been meeting in joint session with
mid suffolk
so item one apologies for absence and
substitutions
thank you chair um i will
roll call members please
um i do believe we haven't received an
apology um from uh councillor gold
members when i call your name can you
please respond um councillor grandin
present
council dawson present
councillor mccraw
present
council mclaren president
and councillor adrian osborne
the morning prison thank you chair
right item two to receive declarations
of pecuniary and non-pecuniary interest
by members are there any to declare
no in that case we'll move on to item
three to receive notification of
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme
non-received chair thank you very much
question uh
item four questions by the public
non-received chair and item five
questions by councillors
non-received chair thank you so now move
to the first substantive item on today's
agenda which is bos 20 stroke one town
center parking in baber district
we don't have a clear idea of what time
we spend on any one item but please bear
in mind we do have the budget today so
my initial thoughts are that we should
spend about an hour or more
on this subject but obviously we do not
restrict ourselves in any way by doing
so that's the basic idea
this report was deferred at the baba
cabinet meeting on the 7th of january
and forwarded to this committee for
scrutiny
the recommendations from this meeting
will be presented to babera cabinet on
the 4th of february this year
however they will also be tabled for
information at the council meeting
tomorrow the 19th of january where a
petition on parking will be debated
now parking is an executive function
therefore cabinet are the decision
makers in respect of this matter not the
full council
this committee will be conducting a
pre-scrutiny of the parking report and
may resolve to make recommendations to
cabinet ahead of its own consideration
of the report
and whilst i know that the
this issue may be of significant
personal interest to several members
i'm asking members to take a wider view
than just any ward considerations that
they may have
made the opportunity to exercise those
views might be more appropriate at the
council meeting tomorrow
i do expect this committee will uphold
its impartial and a political role in
scrutinizing this report
and i will intervene if any if i
consider any counsellor to be making any
overtly political points or if the
debate veers away from the matter in
hand
whilst i want to ensure that the
committee is able to have a very full
and robust discussion
i would also remind councillors that we
have these other important matters to
scrutinize today namely the council's
budget and would respectfully suggest or
ask that all council committee members
ensure that their comments are
relevant and succinctly put
now i'd like to like to ask councillor
malvisi cabinet member for environment
to introduce report bos stroke 20 stroke
one
thank you chairman
before i give my brief intro
introduction i thought it might be
helpful to explain that the report you
have before you which you touched upon
in your opening remarks town center
parking report originally prepared for
the cabinet meeting on the 7th of
january
as no doubt you're aware the report was
not considered at that meeting but was
instead deferred
so that it could be considered by
overview and scrutiny committee today
so that the petitions submitted can then
be debated at full council tomorrow
night therefore this report will be
rewritten to take into account the
discussions both at this meeting and
tomorrow night
together with the various other
submissions received from members of the
public
consequently it will be a different car
parking report with amended
recommendations that the cabinet will
consider at its february meeting
several fellow councillors have asked me
why i'm proposing a motion on car
parking
many presume car parking as a political
hot potato that is too dangerous to
touch
however we're not elected to run scared
of controversial issues we're elected to
try and do our very best for our
district
the best way i can explain explain my
reasoning is by recounting a request
from our council chairman councillor
grandin
catherine asked me to meet her to assess
the small car park at the at hadley
railway walk
together we visited this
sorry excuse for a car park the grass
verges were practically non-existent the
surface of the car park was not only
worn away but there were large dips
where you could see that the edge to the
grass verge had disappeared
and the ground was well gouged out
in fact the tyres on my car disappeared
below the surface this was not a car
park but potentially a swimming pool in
wet weather
also the signage was poor it too needed
replacing
in fact the whole car park needed
improving but i could see that this was
obviously going to cost a lot of money
to rectify
what also struck me were the number of
commercial vehicles parked there i
suspect these weren't plumbers and
electricians walking their dogs
and anecdotally i've been informed that
people actually park there all day
it was this experience that has led me
to look more closely at all the car
parks i use
girling street in sudbury could do with
sprucing up north street well i didn't
really know it existed when i first
arrived here
but recently been resurfaced yet the
bays are so small
and now they're not very clearly marked
because they're worn the entrance and
exit
also leaves much to be desired
the car park outside the kingfisher
center is confusing if you're not
from sudbury
relating my experiences to cassandra
clements our assistant director
it was felt that the costs being borne
by baber for discretionary services
meant that money which could
and possibly should be spent on other
things were suffering
as we all know the importance of car
parking is not just in the quality of
the facilities for each motorist
but in their effective car parking
management
which should be designed to balance
traffic management and environmental
impact
with support for local residents
visitors workers and the economy
introducing the climate change action
plan followed by the biodiversity plan
also highlighted the need for bicycle
parking
currently
they're very pretty tied to the
royaltine railings around saint peter's
church
why because of scant provision for
cyclists
both action plans also address the need
for electric vehicle charging points
both for cars and electric bikes
fundamentally for baber to successfully
deliver all these objectives for our
residents then change is needed
but the question remains as to how such
improvements should be funded
to make our car parks move toward a
position where they are able to stand
alone
without incurring costs to be born by
baby taxpayers then something different
has to be done
i think at this stage i should also give
you a bit of my personal background here
so that you fully understand where i am
coming from
i ran the only mba in retailing and
wholesaling at the institute for retail
studies at stirling university
i was one of the first graduate intakes
to marks and spencers
and i can tell you that people do not
drive to a town simply
to park for free
they drive to a town that offers them
what they are looking for and if what
they want is not available they then
drive to wherever it is available
whether that be berry or colchester or
braintree or halstead
where parking is not free
or they might prefer to go online
the retail mix in hadley is very
different to sudbury
it is obvious from the mix that hadley
gets used by shoppers who shop regularly
they are there are two butchers an
award-winning delicatessen and a new
green grocer deli indicating people are
buying to meet a daily or weekly shop
the offering is instant and personalized
and not chain store driven
which further indicates they tend not to
shop online
unfortunately the opposite is true of
sudbury here the offering is driven by
chain stores who also have a strong
presence
in the online market
stores like boots waitrose iceland
sainsbury's and of course the out of
town tesco
even the banks are online now all of
this impacts on the retail service set
and service sector offering
why would you drive to sudbury
what is there there
that you can't get in a tesco or
sainsbury
however
there are very exciting plans to develop
the centre of sudbury and in fact the
plans fit in with a town centre review
about to be published by the institute
for retail studies
and also bill grimsey's acclaimed review
into the future of the high street
um those who don't know who bills
grimsey is he was the former ceo of
iceland
who have retained a high street presence
probably on the edge of a primary
location
the irs review has identified the need
for our town centres to be greener by
offering facilities for both cyclists
pedal and electric
the claim that free parking will bring
people into shop is a fallacy people
will travel if the offering is what they
want
sudbury has not moved with the times
i'm sure there are people who will
remember the marx and spencer's store
m s
are an anchor store facility
in nearly all our towns
and yet they packed up and pulled out
why
because the footfall was inadequate
and this was before covet
therefore this confirms my earlier
statement that free parking does not
bring shoppers into town of course both
sudbury and hadley have a lot to offer
the tourist sector too
and in fact both are pursuing this
in sudbury you have gainsborough house
and the history of silk
in hadley benton end when i was a
newcomer to the area i discovered that
the car parks were not easily
identifiable
this is obviously a problem for tourists
too
where can i park for the day
but where can i park so that i can do
what i need to do like go to the bank or
visit booths
will waitrose let you park for three
hours while you go up to the market
no they won't
they might give you two hours
while you shop in their store
but not to go elsewhere
i believe that a revised policy is
needed a policy that moves our car
parking provision into the 21st century
that enables car parking to be a
financially self-sufficient service that
produces a revenue stream which will
enable us to move to more sustainable
travel
such as
hopper bus services encourage visitors
to use the appropriate car park
that encourages walking round the town
to thus see what is on offer
now is the time for us to make the
changes that will ensure that our towns
and villages are sustainable
and that they thrive into the future for
all our residents visitors our economy
and our environment
it's time to move away from the approach
to parking that may have worked in the
70s or 80s but no longer does today
it's time for us to be brave
and have the courage of our convictions
and before i close i'd like to say thank
you to
cask
cassandra clements and her team for
having worked diligently on this report
thank you very much
thank you very much councillor mlvc for
your introduction
um i would assume at this point that
officers will be then taking us through
and our consultants will be taking us
through the content of the report
and i'd like to ask if
if that would be carried out by account
cassandra clements the uh
strategic director concerned
good morning thank you very much
that's fine that's fine thank you very
shall we much on
what is in a name hey hey
um thank you very much so um yes as
counselor mal vasey said i've got um a
couple of colleagues here with me today
um i've got oliver fares who has helped
um with this report and also richard
walker from the north essex parking
partnership who uh is our expert in
parking
so um as as councillor malvesy said this
report was prepared for cabinet and so
was set out in that fashion
um so what what i would like to do if
possible is just draw attention to a
number of areas i'm sure uh people on
overview scrutiny committee will have
some questions about um
a number of options were considered and
and as you will i'm sure uh appreciate
the report had a number of iterations um
all of this was based on a study that
was take take place in february last
year um definitely a quieter part of the
year that's acknowledged to to
understand who was using the car parks
for what reason and how long their stays
were happening
so one of the major things that we have
to make sure that we do is when any um
parking um changes take place that they
have to be based upon some kind of
strategic need
and therefore it was understanding who
was using the car parks for what reason
and for how long and one of the major
things that we saw was that turnover was
a real issue in the car parks closest to
our shops and town centres
the out the the more outlying car parks
um were
free there were spaces free there was
availability yet what we saw in the
closer car parks were people queuing
people idling and people um certainly in
sudbury going around the gyratory system
to come back and and check the spaces
out one of the things that we were asked
to look at was whether there was enough
appropriate parking in our car parks and
what we saw from that data was that if
people who were using car parks for
long-stay stays such as commuting
or going to work if they were in our
outer lying car parks it would free up a
good amount of availability in those
closer so you'll see in the report we we
refer to short stay in long stay
and that's what we mean by that so
people who are commuting or people who
are going to work for a shift um in the
long stay car parks really does free up
spaces in the short stay for those that
need to pop in for that more um shorter
brief visit into the town centre
so just a bit of a background as to as
to
why we came up with the options that we
did really
it is noted that a
much wider
um
review strategy review is needed for
parking this is this is literally the
tip of the iceberg this is the the first
bite into what needs to be looked at
across the whole of baby um to see what
is needed in terms of the future in
terms of supporting further the vision
vision work that's going on
and of course our growing population
so you'll see that the report touches on
some of those so some of the visioning
and and how it links into that
there is budgetary considerations in
this as well um and as councillor
melvisi said um every every local
authority really um is always
endeavoring to try and cover its costs
we are all in serious financial
situations
and where we can
we
need to try and cover those costs of
those services
as councillor mount vesey um clearly
stated not only does this service not
cover its costs it's not investing in
its service as well
one of my
biggest beliefs is that someone visiting
a place who parks in a car park that is
the start and the end of their journey
and no matter how good the visit was to
the place that they were going if they
have a bad experience at the start and
the end i do wonder how much that um
that taints them coming back again and
so investing in our car parks for me is
a is a
huge area that we want to see and that
currently simply isn't the ability to do
that
so you'll see that there's a number of
um
options below that we're considered and
a presented option um that we have gone
for which is the option two preferred
option and i'll just talk you through
briefly why we have have done that one
of the things that i mentioned was the
need to link any changes to a strategic
um reasoning
and that strategic reasoning
predominantly is around those
availability of spaces and using a
tariff as a tool
to help people change their behavior
and so the 30-minute free option within
the structured tariff afterwards was
chosen um off the back of the data and
off the back of information from our
consultant here richard walker to to try
and change people's behaviors to park in
the most appropriate car park
in in our towns um we have got the
luxury of a number of different car
parks
which means that we can push longer
stays out to the more outlying car parks
and keep the short stays as close as
possible
so just to round up
you'll see further the implications on
the budget there is an element there of
investment both in the car parks and
also the aspiration to
put um
some of the income over to the
sustainable travel agenda that councilor
malvisi spoke about as well
we do have a sustainable transport
officer starting with the council
shortly in and the economy team under
fiona duramel and and that i think is
going to bring some exciting
opportunities that we really hope if
this decision does go through that some
of the income that comes from that will
be pushed over to that to help cover
some of the environmental implications
that we would like to have
i know that's a whistle stop tour chair
but i'm conscious that you have a number
of things on the agenda and you wanted
to try and keep it concise so i'll stop
there
well i think i think cassandra we can
probably uh examine the report by
questioning and we've got witnesses
available i think that would be
a valid way for us to proceed now uh in
preparing for this meeting i've
identified six
points of examination that i think might
be useful for members
and and i think we should address i'm
suggesting we address
uh the questioning in the same order
those are the preparation of the report
and the research involved
um and i might include that i was going
to make it a separate point but also the
levels and types of consultation the
research itself
and any future consultation uh and
review that might be involved
so let's call that one
two would be the structure of the
proposed charging as illustrated in
table two
uh the changes the differences in the
locations and their needs and and the
other parking provision in our town
centers because obviously our sites do
not exist in isolation
uh the next item would be the very
principle of subsidised parking the cost
of this
uh providing a subsidy
whether that is fair
and also the overall strategy that was
referred to in both your remarks and
those of councillor malvisi
the budget impact obviously is a key
matter which we were going to
examine anyway
and what budget alternatives might exist
so that has to be discovered and finally
the covid 19 impacts which has come to
dominate all aspects of council
operations in the course of the last
year
and perhaps will do so for the
foreseeable future
so members what i would like to ask is
if we can ask our questions in those
orders starting off
with the preparation of the report the
research
consultation
uh future consultation and review so if
we could address questions on that
subject to offices for starters and then
we'll move on to the next subject and
we'll see how we go from there and if
anything else emerges in the course of
the meeting so be it we will follow up
everything that is brought up
so uh questions from members
uh counselor jan gould jane gould
actually i think it says it's got jan
here i apologize jane councillor gould
do you have any questions on that point
no
okay we'll move on then to counselor
adrian osborne
thank you thank you mr chairman thank
you steering crickets there for a minute
thank you mr chairman uh yeah
at this moment i have no questions on on
this and i'll
defer comments later thank you okay
thank you councillor mary mclaren
thank you chair
thank you
i do have a question
um
this paper is very comprehensive
and i think is a credit to those who
have
put it together
but what is seems to me as an outsider
i'm not
emotionally involved with the parking
problem
um is
the
subsidising of the car park especially
in sudbury has become the major focal
point
of of the
you know of the residents
and it's missing all the rest of that
report
um
is this was this anticipated by the
group that put the report together that
this might become quite
um
a very um important point for the
residents
we've seen it because we've all had
information sent to us by various
residents this is really critical to
them
did the the group not consider that that
ought to be
separate
a separate issue
uh to the main recommendations which i'm
going to support anyway
and because the subsidizing of the
parking is not a new issue i would
assume
how my question perhaps in addition to
what i've said
is
how long
has baba district council been
subsidizing the parking in hadley
thank you
substantive question there how long have
we been subsidizing parking in our town
centers for
um okay thank you chair and thank you
councillor mclaren for the question it's
uh it's a very good question actually
because that the parking service has
always had a subsidy um because the um
only charges they've ever been in have
been long-stay charges they've never
come close to
um covering
either the expenditure for the service
nor development so it has always had a
subsidy
and you're right sorry just to answer
that i think there was a park question
there wasn't there as well which was um
the group did anticipate this absolutely
i think when people see that they are
subsidizing a service that they don't
use there is always um a usual words an
emotional reaction absolutely and that's
understood and
unappreciated um we didn't feel
that there was any way of detangling
that from this report because um
all of the actions with it are so
intertwined
it felt a little false to try and take
that out of it
as councillor malvezi said it's a very
hard subject um and we just wanted to
grasp the nettle i guess in in one go
okay i have questions awaiting from
council thank you
thank you very much
i have uh questions waiting from
councillors dawson and grandin but uh
councillor malvisi you have your hand
raised did you wish to comment on the
last question
thank you chairman i just wanted to say
to the committee
that
having studied in glasgow
and walked the streets of the gorbals
canvassing
um
i haven't since then i have not
encountered
the
shall we say the animosity
that this
that this uh motion has raised in
certain quarters
point made but i think i think we're
trying to you know we'd like to actually
just uh put some
remove the heat from the subject by a
rational examination um councillor
dawson you're next i think uh yes thank
you um yes i think it's a very excellent
um report that came in and was very
interesting reading
um
and
one of the things that really concerned
me about this and i i fully accept that
clearly
we it has been subsidised and i realized
that parking payments will have to be
introduced
but you know i know you're new to this
um liz but what i just find um is quite
extraordinary is that this has been
brought in
without any communication
with the ward councillors
um with hadley town council you know the
mayor and the town council it was very
very upset and it has been focused
completely around sudbury
and there's been absolutely no
consultation with the stockholders or
shoppers and local residents in hadley
at this point in time
now we've got the comprehensive parking
strategy review coming 2021
so i just failed to understand other
than trying to slip this through
obviously in the budget
why this was done in january without any
communication or s
consultation i mean perhaps because you
might be able to
that's that's the question so uh the
timing and the and the nature of the
consultation well i just don't
understand why they why they just sort
of came out with this in january because
it smacks of being pushed through very
quickly hidden in the budget
i think it's fairly clear that my
structured uh points of examination are
going to go by the wayside and we're
going to go at it bit by bit that's fine
whatever works the main thing is
actually i've gone through the report
yeah given which is very good and i've
gone through it so and because you
suddenly announced your six uh
you know we've got i've just gone
through the report quite logically i
appreciate it absolutely look let's
let's take those questions uh that uh we
we just asked regarding the uh
stakeholders regarding the timing of um
of preparation of the report i want to
come back to that later cassandra could
you uh could you answer that for us
please
yes of course thank you chair and thank
you councillor dawson for the question
um so the
the
report
i'll take a step back there has been a
corporate objective for some time to
look at parking in baber um so i've been
with the council around uh 18 months now
and it was on my set of
objectives when i came in to to look at
what is going on with the parking
provision in baber um but the report
itself um
has been
in the process of being written since
february last year when we started the
parking survey i mentioned earlier about
collecting the data on the uses of the
car park and originally this was going
to go to
um a november last year cabinet
unfortunately the caverd situation meant
that we had to down tools on quite a few
large pieces of important work um and so
it's been pushed so i appreciate the the
look of it coming right before the
budget it was supposed to be some months
before and i apologize for the delay in
that
um
in terms of the involving stakeholders i
do agree i think stakeholders are always
essential to large strategic decisions
in this case they
there was an initial phase of
is the car parking appropriate and what
is it being used for with the knowledge
that a larger fuller car parking
strategy needs to be developed
they tend to take around a year and a
half to do because of the amount of
consultation that's undertaken in them
what we needed to do was address some
issues within the town centres quicker
which is why we have looked at this
separately and first
what i would say is that that wider um
strategy piece of work that we are
recommending to happen
absolutely would be um
stakeholders would be thoroughly
consulted with
what i will just say is during the if if
this were to go ahead um our parking
orders have to be changed and within
that there is a statutory notice to put
out to the public and to stakeholders to
consult with them so there is the
opportunity with stakeholders to consult
um
on these specific changes
as part of that traffic order change
okay councillor dawson did you want to
follow up on that well well yes because
i mean you've made it quite clear here
that it was pushed back from sort of
february to november so i'm i'm
presuming um by
judging by the history that this can be
pushed back again further because what's
really clear here
um and we'll move on to this
is that the way in which the
recommendations came about
um very clearly
the way they were actually you know it
was done at a low impact point
uh it was a snapshot study it's
informative observations now i think we
need to discuss this a bit later on
so the point i'm trying to make here is
you kept pushing it back suddenly the
budget's coming along you thought oh
quickly put it in there because we need
money and actually when you look at the
figures here well you know i understand
63 percent of this is all sudbury and i
understand that we need to introduce um
a tariff there's no question about that
but for somewhere like hadley
you know we've got a 45 000 pound
deficit and you're suddenly saying
you're introducing these measures when
you haven't actually looked at the
impact uh you've talked about uh you
know all the reasons for doing it uh to
balance traffic management environmental
impacts actually you haven't looked at
any of that in hadley or in sudbury so
it's being rushed through
um and and
this is what's concerning me about all
of this for both towns
but i fully accept tariff has to be
introduced you know
okay we're at questions at the moment
and we don't want to enter into debate
too fast uh councillor grandin you've
been very patient would you like to ask
any questions
thank you
um thank you chair uh in fact uh
councillor dawson has very well
expressed some of the questions i was
going to ask
um i have some further ones
um i'd be interested to know how much
research you actually did
in hadley as councillor dawson mentioned
because some of the
aspects noted in the report for bringing
in
for
um the objectives of charging for
parking such as churn and you mentioned
today searching for parking spaces
that actually doesn't happen very often
in hadley perhaps when there's a
particular event on or on perhaps some
saturday mornings but most of the time
that doesn't happen
so you could maybe
charge just for saturday mornings
perhaps if you wanted to change behavior
such as that
not that i think that's necessary but if
that was one of your objectives
because we don't actually in hadley
have such a bad issue um requiring
regular churn especially since we've had
um
parking enforcement
secondly i agree completely um with
councillor dawson
in questioning your reason for bringing
it in at this time
i'd like to know why
um
you
brought it in for the january cabinet
meeting when
obviously not only covered but also the
christmas break meant that people
couldn't
um
get involved
easily
in the
in the in the debate
um it seemed to be
done to
specifically avoid
public
um
involvement
so
this is is a big concern of mine
um also um
we're here meant to be
looking at the
content of the report
can i ask you why dedham was included as
a good example
of a place to come
as an exemplary place
i visited dead many times during the
summer
and it was complete chaos
so i find that quite interesting people
weren't using the car parts last summer
they were parking in the streets so now
i presume they must have been parking in
the streets to avoid parking parking
fees
um the there was complete chaos you
couldn't
um
you couldn't pass along the road
so i'm interested to know why dedham was
chosen as an example it's a village
anyway not a town
um
and i
i also think your other example of um
the other essex example by by the sea
west west mercy yeah was a poor example
as well so so i don't think they're
comparable
with
the towns we have in baby okay
right we've got they're my initial
questions thank you i mean there is a
lot in there but fundamentally it's
coming back to the the preparation of
the report um the inclusion of this that
can i just clarify one thing though if
councillor grandin doesn't mind i took
the reading of the list of the car parks
to be just that a list
that it although the report says town
center parking it actually does include
all parking provision within babe
district council's control and i felt
that was implicit in the report so
therefore there would be reason for
inclusion of of of uh flatford mill and
and so on uh the comparisons are there
as comparators but
cassandra could you comment on those
those questions please
of course yes so so just to cover what
was done in terms of research i believe
that was the first question um so as i
said there was the initial data study
which was observations of
offices done by
a company called alpha parking who
are used
by local authorities
across the united kingdom when it comes
to
parking surveys so they visited on both
weekdays and weekends to observe
the journeys that people were having the
stays that people were having i
apologize
as to the turnover and the type of
length of stays and that's what we use
to be able to gather some data we also
used um where
possible
we've got ticket machines that are used
even if people are having a free stay so
there's a number of car parks where you
still have to take a ticket so between
the two that's where the data came from
and then also
as i've said uh with me today is a
colleague richard walker from the north
essex parking partnership who we have
used as a consultant who has got a vast
amount of experience in parking
and also works alongside the british
parking association so
his expert knowledge of other areas was
used as well
hopefully that answers the first
question
and the second question
around the timing um so i'm
i'm very sorry if councillors feel that
this was done um to
to hide this report in any way it simply
isn't the case so this report was due to
go to november the covert situation has
absolutely overwhelmed offices in many
areas of the council and we have hacked
to down tools to be able to respond to
both
um the ongoing recovery effort but also
the growing response effort so
it was pushed from november the work
started in february and it was due to go
to the november cabinet and it was
pushed because of that um i think the
amount of
um interaction that we've had from the
public in both the petition and in
questions to councillors shows that
people absolutely did um see the paper
read it and respond to it so i don't
think we've got any issue with people um
not being able to take part in the
democratic process
and and councilman mccor actually
started to answer my third the third
question there but i'll just uh
thank you very much no not at all um but
i'll just just add to that i'm sorry if
you think they're poor examples um i i
actually thought because dedham is
shared border with us and has two um
very good car parks there that that was
an excellent example and the other one
west mersey just shows that tourist
attraction that we've got in baber as
well where people go to visit and i have
got
richard walker with me as i said who
happens to manage those two particular
car parks
so if there's any questions specifically
about those then i'm i'm happy to bring
him in and but i'm not entirely
entirely sure what the question was
about the examples or just whether it
was they they weren't
accepted um
so if i can come back on that dead end
point just quickly because i know it's
not a central point
um
i found
if if that is the
situation that results from introducing
parking
that is not a very good advocate for
bringing in
parking fees because i found complete
and utter chaos there when i visited
many times last summer
um because people were trying to avoid
parking there because they're all parked
in the streets
to avoid parking fees so i would say
that would be a reason to
not create a very
um
well-managed situation
um just come back on that point then
just to just to clarify i think
we'll move if we made a councillor
dawson of course um so i'll bring in
richard walker because i think he could
probably give you some specifics about
the usage of that car park certainly my
knowledge of i previously used to work
for colchester borough council and so
know dedham fairly well on the essex
side um there
on the essex side and the baby side
there have been
issues with on-street parking for quite
some time and what tends to happen is
there is on the border they on on street
um
parking restrictions were put in to try
and deal with the ongoing issues on the
street and that has pushed the issue
into baby somewhat my understanding and
i'll let richard um substantiate this if
there's its case is that the it's not
that people are trying to avoid avoid
car parking at all um it's that dedham
gets overwhelmed with tourists
is an exceptionally popular place for
people to go
on top of and people dog walking in the
in the villages using it so but i'll
bring in richard walker at this point
who i think could probably give you a
better answer of the kind of usage of
that car park thanks cass good morning
everybody um i manage north essex
parking partnership um six districts
across north essex so we share quite a
long border um with braintree with um
braintree colchester and almost
tendering with uh with the baby district
deaden um there's an interesting place
lots of cars too many cars on occasion
and that's really is a
brought in this example of somewhere
that charging has been introduced to
show that introducing charging doesn't
keep people away
now part of the issue with dedham is is
also the flatfoot side which is in babe
suffolk side
and charging used to be introduced at
flatfoot to dissuade people from parking
there but instead use dead and where
there are more parking facilities and to
take a walk along the river and visit
flatford and uh all of the amenities
that the valley has to to offer
since that's happened of course dead has
now become overwhelmed by people
choosing to park at dedham
but there we are the the car park is in
fact very very well used and we've got
our own statistics to uh suggest that
and there's some overflow parking as you
rightly say but too many cars is a
problem there so the introduction of
charging doesn't in fact keep people
away from places um quite the reverse it
would seem um and the west mersey was
introduced
into the report as well
to show that
managing parking by way of controls and
there we have a free stay and then some
introduced charging uh helps manage the
car park we had a particular problem
with high streets there where people
were parking all day and preventing
people from going to the local shops in
west merson which is the town
from uh from shopping there and uh the
introduction of charging there has been
welcomed by the town council since um
it's been uh it's been introduced and as
has really helped manage um the way that
works there's some other intro um
examples in the report as well with
nantwich and brydport and helmsley all
sort of towns i was thinking of towns of
a similar sort of uh size um all of
which i've knowledge of as well and uh
can say that it works very very well in
those places as well i've visited those
obviously it's hadley quite a lot i live
not too far distant even though i manage
parking in essex i know
exactly what goes on hadley
and uh
i've used the health center in hadley a
lot there there's some other issues
going on there in in terms of the
investment and the layout of things
which are included in the report which
are
as pertinent to some of the other things
to hadley
and the investment of course um does
cost some money but we need to start by
thinking about um that balance from from
transportation the environment and the
town centre vitality and support of our
all our policies so it's it it's
important to have that balance i think
when we're thinking about things like
that
thank you
thank you very much mr walker uh
councillor dawson you wanted to come
back i believe
or was it councillor grandin next i i
wasn't sure there sorry um yes cassandra
if i can just come back
uh what you haven't really addressed in
here at all
is when you when the when the um
reports were done the reason for the
decision making etc
you've sort of gone to sudbury but you
haven't looked you know it's comparing
hadley and sudbury and the rural areas
out where mary is um
you know you haven't actually looked at
the displacement of the traffic
and you seem to have applied
um
a universal tariff
which i can't quite understand why and
i'm still not getting an answer from you
as to why
this is not being pushed back
um and suddenly you've already looked at
it very carefully hardly you haven't and
why this is not being pushed back till
after the parking strategic review
i mean we've got that you know you've
shown quite clearly there are certain
things for lavender so they've been
excluded but i can't understand why
you're implying
applying
all this on hadley when absolutely no
research has been done there
and i can't understand how the cabinet
member either is letting this go through
without any
you know they've not gone and done any
well
research perhaps cassandra we could have
the um officers involved in the
preparation of the report this was
something i was wanting to move to where
we could actually ask what how the
preparation of the report was done
the timing involved there is one point i
thought i should make is that it's been
a come apparent to me in researching and
pla preparing for this meeting
that um some um
some of this constraint on time
obviously planned for november had to be
brought through to january bringing it
up now uh if we don't do it now am i
correct in thinking that we would miss
the opportunity to put it into this
year's budget and he would have to wait
till next year's budget now i'm not sure
the situation we that exists at the
moment is necessarily sustainable so i
don't i don't think this is necessarily
a a planned exercise i think this is
just a a matter of fact is that we've
got no choice but to do it but now
honestly could i just come back to you
on that comment
and it doesn't have to be applied to the
whole of the district very clearly
looking at the figures here
um
can i finish well you can but we're in
questions at the moment
sorry if i can just come back because
you're leading us on is
you're suggesting that we we can
actually take towns out of this and put
other you know 65 of this is sudbury and
i fully accept tariffs need to be
introduced as i do in hadley as well
let's be really clear about this but
it's the options and the way it's being
done and we'll be moving on to that i
have i have tried to suggest that we try
to keep uh some of these comments on
individual matters in individual towns
um
away from this meeting we're looking at
the report here we're not examining the
individual concerns of hadley or sudbury
in this instance we're looking at the
report as a totality
now i would like to have the questioning
directed towards the report rather than
some specific examples those i think
will be better raised as i have
suggested at tomorrow's council meeting
simply for a matter of going through
this report
systematically and and doing it justice
now at the moment i think we're getting
a little bogged down in these individual
matters so what i'd like to do now uh is
to move on to the structure of the
proposed charging um because that seems
to me to be a large portion of the issue
i understand you you're raising your
hand councillor brandon but i think for
the moment which you need just to move
on we will have an opportunity for
everybody to speak again and come back
in the debate section but it seems to me
a lot of the questioning is is largely
making debating points okay i have a
question that's relevant to that
fine can we come back to that will i
just can i come out with a question i've
got here and then we'll come back to you
yes my question is concerning proposed
charging anyway so well that's fine
let's let's move to that point because i
did want to ask some questions about the
scale and structure of the charging and
one of my points was what other parking
provision
exists within these communities that is
not controlled by baby district council
i wonder if somebody could describe the
other parking provisions and the sort of
level of charging uh held in those
sure thank you very much um chair so i
know uh richard has done a lot of work
on what other parking provision is
around in terms of car parks but what i
would just add is that clearly there is
on-street parking that is not charged
for that is managed by the highway
authority suffolk county council so
there is all of the normal um bay
parking
um and on street parking that is
available that um there is no suffolk
county council don't charge for any of
their on-street car parking currency
both high streets cassandra or just the
one
i mean
and hadley
that's everywhere so it's sudbury
hudbury
and there are there is a lot of
on-street parking that is still
available uh either just through um
it's on street and there are no traffic
orders in place um or through bay
parking so actually so for instance
market hill in sudbury um is thought of
as a car park it's actually on streetcar
parking and it is managed by suffolk
county council there is a suffolk county
council overall strategy referred to in
the report and it's one of the
supporting documents
does that describe any change in
thinking regarding suffolk county
council's policy for on-street parking
and and what length of time can one park
for free for example on these these high
street
shops
so there will be um
if there is no traffic regulation order
in place there and therefore no lines
then you can park for as long as as as
wanted there isn't a restriction
some places have restrictions so some
say um
maximum of three hours
some
of the bay parking for instance may have
restrictions of 30 minutes in some of
our high streets um but it is it's all
free and they they all depend on the
traffic regulation order that's in place
so it's a little hard to to say exactly
what because they're going to be
different in different places i had i
had a description supplied to me um that
you could park for example in hadley
high street for uh
one hour for free
is that yeah you're right i see yes yes
indeed that is an accurate statement i
mean that's right i i'm not a driver but
i have been in many cars which i've had
to park i usually am the one who has to
pay the parking fee
so i'm quite used to these up and down
the country okay that was my first point
the structure of the charging um is
interesting to me i look at the
structures and i see
what i'd have to say seem to be
relatively small figures
um 50p a pound and two pounds for the
most part and all day parking for four
pounds in many cases now
i i
i seem to recall and i'm pretty sure i'm
right the parking costs in uh
multi-story car parks in colchester and
ipswich and maybe berries and edmonds
are considerably higher than that is
that accurate and again i i haven't been
into some of these places for nearly a
year now
for obvious reasons
um
are those are the are the figures much
lower than i mean you have comparators
in other authorities and you have um
regardless of whether people think they
are directly comparable we have
comparators from across the country
um
are we satisfied that those are
reasonable figures that uh describe a
situation that does exist across the
country
that's right so i'll bring richard
walker in on this point because uh he
was um fundamentally responsible for
what that structure would look like on
the basis of his experience of what
other people charge what i will just say
is that we did believe in comparison to
what others charge our neighbours and
further afield that these were far more
modest charges than um are being used in
other tariffs um but i'll hand over to
richard to talk about that structure
thank you very much so the um the
parking tends to follow the the
destinations offer and uh the amount of
parking that is provided tends to
reflect the the sort of offer that the
town has
so we've looked around at some of the
other places i mentioned earlier across
the country nationally and also locally
and um these sorts of places that uh are
quite similar to sudbury and hadley
do have similar sorts of tariffs to this
and the larger towns tend to have a
slightly higher
tariff now the reason for the tariff
isn't firstly to make money the reason
for the tariff is to try and get people
to think about the type of stay they're
having uh the
type of trips they're making and and to
some uh degree to influence people to
try and use different mode of transport
if they possibly can and a relatively sh
small um or short change
in
the way people travel
modes people use
has quite a big impact on the congestion
on the network
so for things like longer stays that's
that's the reason those tend to be
higher
and the influence there is to try and
get people to use other modes now
parking at the kerb side you've
mentioned parking is free
there's a hierarchy of control generally
in that
spaces
tend to be shorter stays in the high
street near the town centre and that's
really for popping into the shop and
there's a very high churn
there but where you'd really like people
to park for a longer day is in the car
park that's why you have car parks
there's a very good tool that suffolk
county has called traffweb
which shows you the types of studies
that can be made in the kerbside
the hierarchy of control there includes
residential parking
and some other
different
techniques to control double yellow
lines and other controls as you stretch
um down the roads that lead into the
town centres
so parking generally
is a function of the thing that's
available there and um to look around as
other places to look around at the
demand to look around at uh the the
other types of influences that we're
trying to uh
both
now and in the future
try to manage so we looked at the
visioning for for a bit further forwards
as well and the sorts of things that
might happen in the future to try and
put a tariff in which is going to manage
the sorts of parking with the available
space we've currently got
um so there's there's there's the
reasoning behind that the tariff
structure um now what we'd like people
to do uh because we've looked at the the
length of stays the average length of
stays uh the most common stays the types
of stays that there have been
where people pay we'd like that to give
a lot more value to the length of stay
that people have so if they were to put
in 50p they'd stay for the whole hour um
and at the moment some some of those
stays are much much shorter so there's
there's all sorts of different
influences going on there and as soon as
you scratch the surface on this as we've
already discovered the thing becomes far
more complex
and matter than just like oh we'll pop
pop a pound on there or something it's
it does get much more detail than that
when you when you start to look at the
um the other impacts we're trying to get
um
a tariff in there that reflects the sort
of provision that there is the sort of
churn that we want the spaces and the
the popularity of the car parks at the
moment and also as a byproduct of that
which is some income which can pay for
investment improvement um as we go on
thank you very much uh mr walker uh
councillor mclaren next i think we'll
come back to you councillor grandin
though council mccarran
um
can i address a question so mr walker is
that acceptable chairman of course it is
can i ask if he reviewed shotley
peninsula
uh in relation to the or even cassandra
about we're we are very short of car
parks in shotley peninsula and we're a
big tourist attraction
anglia and water
have just put up their parking i'd be
interested in rich's comment on that
anglian water
uh have just put up their
tariff in
um autumn water
what that has done to my villages is
push all the traffic
into quiet lanes
car tracks and in fact in tatting stone
they've had to ask the county council to
make some provision on the roads
and so i would like as a peninsula
councillor to know perhaps uh what we
can do and what we can look forward to
thank you can i just ask for a reference
council mclaren what sort of level the
uh anglian water parking uh fee is for
ultimately so
alistair when i asked the question i
realized that i hadn't actually checked
it was it it was a at one time i think
it was like four pounds for all day yeah
i think they've pushed that up because
when the last time i parked there that's
what it cost i i recall because i'm i'm
nearby you i recall it being something
like that uh but i think it's certainly
two to three pounds even for a short
stay yeah um i mean it's not not in the
same ballpark as perhaps this although
perhaps at a recreational site one might
be expecting to spend more time there i
mean it's a question of usage i think mr
walker has referred to that this is
about usage uh and and cost usage as a
trade-off one against the other now um i
have quite a few hands up i have
councillor grandin uh councillor osborne
and and councillor dawson so we'll take
those uh councillor grand and you were
first then councillor dawson and then
councillor osborne
[Music]
thank you claire
um
i'm pleased that mr walker mentioned the
word offer in his um
uh talk to us because
when you compare the offer
of both sudbury and hadley with some of
the places that were mentioned
they're not really comparable
and then again if you compare the offer
of sudbury compared with hadley they're
not really comparable
um sudbury i mean i
i love my town hadley but we haven't got
a world-class museum in hadley we
haven't got the number of shops
that um sudbury has
we haven't got some of the other we
haven't got a good bus
service as an alternative to parking
we do not have a decent bus service in
in hadley so you cannot expect people to
look to public transport
um
so
that we're not comparable places but
looking at the fee structure
um the fees you're you're planning to
charge are comparable only offering 30
minutes free um
for for hadley
you know we we want people to stay
longer
we want people to stay you know good two
or three hours really
um we want them to use all our
facilities our walk and our our um
hospitality
and so on not just the shops we have a
lot of hospitality in our high street
and that's increasing
you can't do that in half an hour or an
hour you need two or three hours we
would like them to come here and we want
to encourage people to stay
not to dissuade them
so i'm concerned about the structure
of um the pricing and also comparing
that
i'm not you i you give three options i
do see
but
they're not that dissimilar from from
each other so i'm not sure why hadley
and sudbury with their two completely
different offers
are
compared you know where we're a much
smaller town you know ten thousand
and a smaller offer and so on please
could you explain how you
um
how the end result is fairly similar
please the reasons for the difference is
effectively council grand and yes
yes or lack of difference
yeah okay fine the structure again we
come back to the structure
any thoughts and sorry you might have
covered some of this earlier but i lost
my line earlier so i i do apologize if
you've already covered this
because i don't know what i've missed
sorry
no problem at all councillor grandin
that's fine um so
so the structures are different in
strawberry and hadley and i'll i'll
bring um richard walker in a second as
well and and and very much for the
reasons that you've just said in the the
the
users of hadley do tend to stay that
longer period so hence why in the
if we look at the preferred option or
the recommended option for sudbury
you'll see
30 minutes 1 hours 2 hours 3 hours
whereas in hadley there's a 30 minutes 3
and then it's a full 3 three-hour period
so
for me they are different and they are
reflective of the users um but i'll pass
over to richard and to just to talk a
bit more about that structure
yeah they're different and they've been
looked at in in comparison with the type
of town the type of state there are but
it is all parking isn't it but the
problem is is going to be if it isn't
already evident one of too many cars um
and the thing about bus services versus
cars we've almost got ourselves into the
situation because
um and bus services will only exist
where where passengers use them and
that's something that we
one day need to get back uh
to providing and using we all take our
part in traveling appropriately
and and making the the right journeys at
the right times
this is about having the right space in
the right place at the right time
for the right trip
it's about having the right churn in the
spa the parking spaces are there and and
for the future as well um the next
couple of years
we think it's going to be very popular
when we're all allowed out once again
i have been looking at hadley as i said
very regularly i live not too far away
from hadley so i've been looking at
hadley since about 1978 in actual fact
um and have quite a lot of history um in
my mind about the things that have
changed and the sort of offer that you
you get in hadley versus what happens in
in sudbury uh it's a nice unique little
town full of independence and that is
its offer
and with the tariff structure we got on
there pay a pound and get three hours
and that's the sort of thing that the
car park can currently sustain
but again we're thinking about saying
maybe take the choice and and the type
of stay that you have so that you make
space available for others to come and
use it and then invest that in in making
the space so that uh it can be turned
over a bit more appropriately so if we
marked the bay slightly wider it might
be quite a lot more easy to use for
instance magdalen road car park which is
quite difficult to get in and out of
some of the space and you see hit and
miss parking along the long parking bays
at the moment because vehicles have
grown in size
over those 40 years or so and suvs now
much much larger than
what we'd have been driving 40 years ago
and we need to make those changes um and
the consequence of of having charging in
there is some income and that can be
reinvested in in making improvements
back into the car parks so it's a little
bit circular um it's it's all a parking
problem it's about too many cars but
it's about trying to to balance the
right sort of uh provision against the
right sort of stays and influencing
around the edges and people to make the
right choices
mayor come back please
um what i would like to influence more
if we had to introduce parking would be
times of day we the car parks hardly
used during the week
um there are cars but it's not busy we
don't have an issue with churn we'd like
people to come during the week and and
use our our services
we left for debate councillor grandin
because i think we've still got some
ground to cover before we come to other
car parks
um and people will use the roads
and the other and the other thing i
would just like to say is the impact on
our hospitality
and
and um
retailers
by bringing in
charging at all
okay so we've we've got a number of
points but i think there's a best left
for debate if you don't mind my saying
okay thank you councillor dawson and
councillor osborne and if we please
please keep this we are running on a
lengthy time today i'm quite happy to do
that the job has to be done properly
but if we can keep our questions
succinct i'd be grateful
uh richard coming back to what you're
saying then um do you accept and clearly
i hopefully will acknowledge the fact
that um with these tariffs
um the report the the impact was done in
february now let's be really honest 64
minutes
uh most people whether they're younger
or older um this was done in sudbury
it's the coldest time of the year
would you accept that perhaps if the um
study had been done in july that most
people would be staying an hour and a
half perhaps two hours and therefore
really
this should have been an hour rather
than 30 minutes and really we should be
in that ought to be reflected in these
tariffs and actually that option isn't
in here
and and
it slightly surprises me you've you've
picked to do your uh study the worst
time of the year
um because the average person doesn't
really stay 64. if you were to take that
throughout the year it's a lot longer
so i would like to see the periods here
certainly extended to a minimum
in sudbury
if not more maybe in hadley i'm
accepting that we need to introduce
charges but i think the time period
needs to be ramped up because nobody can
do anything in 30 minutes and it's
obvious that this is going to displace
traffic and then we're completely losing
the balance of what we're trying to
achieve here
i think the um the thing about february
is it's the least popular time of the
year
and even at that time of the year the
car parks were getting to be full
so if you interpolate that through to
the busier times of the year you'll see
that people looking for spaces that
aren't there
and they're not there because they're
being filled by people that are parking
the wrong place for too long and that's
what the design of the tariff is there
to
try and promote a change to so we're
trying to stop
long stay or longer stays stays of
nearly three hours in in the shoppers
car parks
move those stays out of the town centre
so that you can move um other shoppers
stays in and reuse those spaces more
than once for the people who are making
the one or two hours days and then the
churn is there
but also spread those stays out
throughout the day by differently
promoting the car parks and differently
promoting the offer of the town
for everybody to
try and get a space at 10 or 11 o'clock
in the morning and stay for three hours
it's not very sustainable you really
want those stays to be spread out
throughout the day and and to be able to
reuse that space more than once to get
the best benefit out of it so that's
there's the the benefit of um trying to
introduce the uh the controls the
tariffs
they study
sorry you're going off a bit of a
tangent i'm participating i'm
specifically talk referring here to the
fact this is about
generating income let's be really clear
about it this is not about balance data
this is about generating income to plug
the gap in sudbury so that's why you've
done 30 minutes because every single
person will have to pay
and all i'm suggesting here is because
you've done your
um
reporting at a bad time of the year
you know that every person is going to
have to pay
and it does
you don't seem to be looking at the
balance here at all
we're back into debate now councillor
dawson i'd like to bring in councillor
osborne with a question please
yeah thank you mr chairman um
my question is is based on on what we're
on your on your six points about the
budget
somebody remembers them
[Laughter]
what is the impact uh if you can clarify
what is the impact on the budget
if the free parking time was kept as is
can i have the figures please
hello councillor osborne sorry could i
just clarify for you so if
when you say the figures as is is how
the budget is now
what yeah what is the impact on the
budget yeah as it is now yeah if the
free parking was kept as it as it is as
it is now are you referring to
not these proposals but the previously
existing ones absolutely indeed okay so
the the current parking budget runs at
185 000 pound deficit so if we keep
parking as it is just with the long term
long stay um charges in that's uh that's
what the baba budget shows
with the subsidiary fact that the
parking provision and the
state
um is not sustainable the car parks are
deteriorating the machines are out of
date that's correct so that's that
doesn't include any further investment
in them so that isn't with a as a
maintenance program there's something of
a double whammy this is not purely for
raising of revenue it is in fact in part
uh a matter of reinvestment into parking
provision in these
places okay
now um
is that your question complete
councillor osborne no i i i would like
the figures for the for this what how
does it how does it present itself in in
in numbers please i thought that
i'm just scrolling down so in um
6.5 onwards you'll see table
4a4b
and they show the current budget for the
service
if um if you would like a further
breakdown of that though counselor
osborne i'm very happy to
send you the breakdown of the full
expenditure is that page 13 tables 4a 4b
and 5. that's right yes page 13. do you
want the net adrian for sudbury no no
that that was fine thank you uh
cassandra it's uh it's wonderful um
a net cost of 185k as shown in table 4b
the top figure which i think is the
figure you were quoting cassandra yeah
that's all right i haven't had an
opportunity to thank cassandra for that
report but uh
no doubt she's aware that i'm i'm very
uh very good so i'd like to ask some
questions myself now um
based on one of the points which is the
very principle of subsidized parking it
cost fairness and the strategy overall
uh
i'd just like to ask officers and the
consultant mr walker whether
the provision of three hours free
parking is anything like a normal
provision
across the country in his experience or
an officer's experience and and what
extent
free parking would normally be provided
for in similar market towns
there may be differences between hadley
and sudbury but their fundamental
character is that of a market town but
perhaps of slightly differing sizes and
one has a a greater catchment area but
fundamentally
that's what they appear to me from my
own travels across the united kingdom
so is this normal
um thank you councilman i will bring in
richard there because he does actually
manage parking in a number of market
towns and so i think can accurately
answer that question
yes six districts that i manage in
across north essex um that's the rural
part of essex that i manage um no it's
very unusual to have
such a long period of free parking
in any of them there's all sorts of
different offers for the type of town
and the offer that the town has to
provide
and i think the individual unique nature
of each town is what needs to be
considered there
in conjunction with the wider
transportation needs of of the area
too many cars too many trips at the
wrong time is always going to cause a
problem and one of the things that
transportation people are trying to
resolve is the use the network and and
how busy places are balanced against the
environmental considerations of
congestion and air quality management
and this is one of the tools in the box
is to try and make people think
differently about the journey they're
making when they're making it
and and how appropriate it is to make it
or in the mode they're choosing
so yes i've traveled widely across
the country myself
cornwall very touristy
definite dorset again quite touristy
quite rural in rural dorset there i've
mentioned bridport in the report
you have a look in the north west
there's big draws of big cities
manchester and liverpool
stoke on trent um but some of the other
smaller towns there um also have
charging involved and
but again reflecting the completely
different nature of that uh if you look
at yorkshire york is a very big pool
you've got leads on the doorstep and the
coast but again
charging is um pretty much universal
there
with one or two exceptions um in the
likes of thirsk but there's a very very
large market square um
any
any free
parking provided
um that's the only one that i can think
of is is the first area in north
yorkshire um where there was a parking
disc that used to be used there
you've named richard aren't really
comparable you're comparing apples and
pears talking about leeds and dorset
um you know i mean lavender we're
already loving them isn't including any
tariffs are they and that's once once
again once again we're getting the paper
yeah so what i'm going to do now as i
suggest is unless are there any more
questions
on
the paper itself or any information that
you want to bring out from the officers
i do have one point i've just
checked out alton waters current charges
are one pound 70 for the first hour
three pounds 70 for up to three hours
and six pounds for five hours stay by
which time you'd have just enough time
to cycle round the whole lake right
uh so if there are no more questions
councillors grand and dawson you both
have your hands raised but i hope this
is for questions yeah just one more it's
about the enforcements actually with
these new options do we have how much
if we would get anywhere from 160 to 580
uh how much of that proportion is
um enforcements
okay is enforcement actually involved in
this report officers well yeah
6.9 tables four being five do not
include costs from patrols and
enforcement so has that been taken into
consideration do
do we actually receive any income from
enforcement or is it more or less a cost
neutral thing for us for to avoid um
to avoid congestion i mean those are the
two points that come to my mind because
i i recall from the congestion uh sorry
from the uh enforcement policy that this
was not expected to be producing any
form of surplus
absolutely so i can confirm what's going
on with enforcement so we have a service
level agreement with both ipswich
borough council and west suffolk council
who share the enforcement across baber
and also mid-suffolk council and we're
about to come to our end of our first
year so it started on the 6th of april
last year though clearly um covered uh
during cover we agreed to stop charging
in car parks and therefore we stopped
enforcing car parks for that same period
um so we haven't had a normal year
however um the we the cost of enforcing
our um car parks is highly unlikely to
be covered by the income coming back
from that that enforcement so um
at the end of march we will have um
a
client meeting with ipswich and with
west to see what income has come back
from those parking tickets and that will
be used to offset the cost of that
enforcement we're not um
looking at upping our enforcement at all
all our towns get um all our car parks
get one or two visits a day monday to
saturday excluding bank holidays um and
so we we are saying that we'll continue
with that same
patrol regime
no matter what happens with the this
report
thank you very much counselor
uh mclaren you have your hand raised
you have a question yes thank you chair
this is a a bit song in cheat really
question
uh there's been so much negative um
publicity
about sudbury um have we had any
positive reaction from the residents who
are going to gain uh residential permits
to park in milan car park overnight
there they're a group of people that
should benefit from this um
interesting point any comments on that
so that was um an an element that was
brought up by one of our cabinet members
from the area who has been in touch with
those residents previously and they have
been requesting for some time some
resident parking because they're they're
clearly there is nothing for the um
in terms of um
their own driveways and there's
certainly nothing on the street anywhere
near them that would be something again
so we know we know that it's a need
there and we know that the residents are
are up for that however we do a full
consultation as i said previously when
we we look to change the parking order
to get their views represented
cost could be fairly described as pretty
modest comparison with uh
some uh city center provisions for
parking permits uh the costs in places
like edinburgh is through the roof
i mean you literally take out a mortgage
on one
or included in your mortgage costs no
i'm sorry that was irrelevant uh i have
a quick question and councillors dawson
and grandin you still have your hands
raised do you have further questions
yes well i'm just wondering why you're
while we're talking about edinburgh here
and as you know cycling
i didn't admit it was irrelevant
but i think cycling is subsidized
so yeah hang on cycling is subsidized
and i do think that um certainly within
this portfolio
it needs to be some form of subsidy
what sort of subsidy is cycling
subsidized by i'm somewhat confused by
that thought we're always being asked we
can keep that for conversation at
another time
i think we need to uh looking at the
motorists what we don't want to be doing
is penalizing the motorist and you know
you should be thinking some form of
subsidy ought to be considered here
right well no mention in the of in the
um certainly on page one here there's no
mention at all for the reason for
decision is this is just about plugging
the finances and it just kind of i don't
know why they don't just sort of
entirely fair council of dawson but
we're coming into debate so if you've
not no questions i will move on
and you have a question
before we go to debate
yes i've got two questions one why did
you
do this before um
the impact of
um
enforcement was known because we have
very little churn issue in hadley and
that is even more so after
um enforcement which is working very
well in hadley and is catching a lot of
people out
second
you don't seem to have considered the
covid impact that was going to be not
0.5 on your list
and we don't seem to have discussed that
at all
um with regard to um
the the timing of the implementation
of the
proposed fees
so on
my second question is regarding
um the covered impacts and timing
um i think that you know we don't know
when we've got things changing a lot in
the country at the moment with
vaccinations but we don't actually know
when um
the impact of
covid is going to
um
make people feel safe going out again
enable shops to start making money again
and hospitality
um so it's going to take them a long
time to recover some of the
um places on our high street are already
um
in a difficult position
um even pre-covered
now we have covered and we all know i
won't need don't need to go into the
details of how this has impacted
hospitality why bring it in july i think
we need to wait till
um
that's the point for the debate we've
got the question we've got the question
counselor i'm sorry to cut you off here
but we really are over running okay
frankly we're repeating ourselves if you
don't mind my saying so now so the
question here i think is covered i've
got one third question um
if they're going to be
have you
considered um residence parking
because obviously
um displacement
can will have an impact on the streets
around the town okay um most you know
many streets of close enough to park in
and then just walk into
the high street and so on okay
thank you thank you thank you thank you
very much so to answer the covert
question and the report was written
in december when at the time that there
was uncertainty about whether there
would be a further national lockdown
clearly now we are in it and we know
that um and councillor malvesi did
mention earlier about the um this item
being here today and also the position
going to council tomorrow could possibly
end in some changes to the report and a
new report going in february so i don't
think there's probably much further i
can say on that but clearly it will be
responding to the current situation as
opposed to when this report was written
in december and in fact just from the
point of view of that that was mentioned
in the introduction that the report that
would be considered by cabinet in
february is likely to be slightly
different and we ourselves will pay a
part in making it that difference in any
recommendations we may wish to make
so what i propose to do now i think
because we covered most things there was
one thing that i would have thought the
kovid 19 impacts is this correct uh
even when it was being considered in
january
the effects of the new strains
um
were not clear is there a capacity
should it be necessary i there i note
that there is a appendix b shows a
timeline for various parts of the
process that carry through to
um year two um but literally take place
across all four quarters of 2021 and
that is the
starting in april i assume
is there a
possibility is it potentially possible
to delay
implementation of certain aspects of
this by three months or by six months
and is that feasible
within budget constraints and within
practical constraints
so thank you chair it is possible and
feasible
to to delay implementation um
the to answer the budget question the
budget gets agreed on the fourth of
february so it wouldn't be included in
that but in terms of implementation yes
it is possible and feasible to delay the
implementation date so the budget
impacts would have to be dealt with
separately that's correct okay thank you
very much um if there are no further
questions my other questions haven't
been answered by apologies which one was
that
one on resident parking parking my
apologies
that's correct
displacement yes absolutely so um the
um baby district council published an
area parking plan and the year before
last which encourages residents who have
issues with parking
to contact us and talk to us about
alternative solutions now obviously on
street as i mentioned earlier is
controlled by suffolk county council but
absolutely district councils play a part
in supporting residents getting changes
made to their to their areas that are
more appropriate for what's going on and
actually lockdown um once civil parking
enforcement came in on the fourth of
april last year lockdown had a great
effect on that many more people were
parking at home
and people found that there were there
were many more issues coming up with
on-street parking and as a district
council we've already been supporting
communities on the process of how to get
that changed and that could be a number
of different things it could be paid
parking it could be resident permits um
it's really for suffolk county council
to decide however we are supporting a
number of residents in um
applying to suffolk county council to
get those changed in their in their
areas so absolutely we will continue to
do that if that became an issue
with displacement
okay
thank you very much
the other question you didn't answer was
um regarding why did you choose
to do
obviously we didn't know that kovid was
about to
affect
the world but you chose february as your
time to um examine things instead of
when you knew that
enforcement was imminent
and that would have a great impact on
and so on has it had such an impact so
my question would be though i don't know
one thing i can say is that even in
february we were not sure that the
statutory
instrument was going to be laid in
parliament for cpe to happen so we
didn't know that until
a little later on and it's been coming
for a number of years now and we had to
do the survey at some point
this that was the point it was done at
it wasn't for any other reason and
actually enforcement would not have um
necessarily changed the the data that
would have got people were going and
staying anyway um and you know the
predominant amount of people park
properly and correctly and don't get a
ticket and so the enforcement would not
have had that much um relevance on the
data
my thought was just that the enforcement
has been very difficult to roll out as
it would have been under covered 19 it
was almost impossible to actually get
the enforcement uh teams out on on sites
or in the localities to be able to do
their job so it's very difficult to
judge one way or the other i'm now going
to move to debate i do see councillor
osborne's hand up was that a question
too uh sorry councillor dawson apologies
uh councillor osborne and councillor
dawson
adrian killed
yeah thank you uh thank you mr chairman
um as i say i'm i'll take it we're going
into debate now and that's what we will
ask the council of dawson's last
question
uh
councillor osborne councillor dawson
yes perhaps i should direct this more um
liz
uh you state quite clearly in the
modelling that a number of alternative
strategies have been discussed
and i just wonder whether you can
clarify what these alternative
strategies were
and why they were discarded for the
report
thank you councillor dawson
as you well know i'm not actually
involved in the modelling
um so i will defer to richard walker who
is the modeler
um
to respond on my behalf
sorry were these it says they would
discuss those were they not discussed at
a cabinet level then
they were
but the different modeling was more on
the pricing structure
but i think your question is actually
more intended on the policy and on the
strategy and policy no i just really
just want a summary of what the
alternatives are for people who are
watching um what the alternative
strategies were
they're in the report
there are three options presented
but these are these are sorry alistair
these are alternative strategies which
were discussed in the cabinet meeting
and they were discarded so we don't need
to drill down too much i mean i know
some algorithms were done and i wouldn't
expect the um apparently i wouldn't
expect detail on that but if liz could
just give a
brief what the alternative strategies
they discussed were and why they were
dismissed the alternative strategies
were option one two and three
and they were discussed at great length
okay i also know that we have
i also know
charging
sorry sorry my customer rvc please if
you can help answer this question that'd
be great
no um
those were the options
personally
personally speaking there are other
options
you know it does say they were discarded
for the report so i'm assuming that
doesn't include options
option three were discarded and the
cabinet settled on option two i'm not
sure
is i'm not sure this is going to lead us
anywhere um i don't think so
appendix a which gives the principles
and interventions that are necessary to
describe the the entire approach and i
think that probably seems to me
a good introduction to what will be an
emerging strategy because actually a
strategy review is part of the potential
recommendations
exactly so i'd now like to open things
up for debate unless councillor osborne
has a question i have an order for
debate and this is basically because of
the nature of remote meetings uh a
free-for-all can be complicated so i'll
ask councillor mary mclaren if she would
like to open the debate
um and then we'll move on through the
other councillors in the order i have in
front of me
everybody will have their opportunity to
speak
um aaron
thank you chair um
i think we should be debating
the method of consultation
um i accept all the reasons that have
been given for the consultation
but we certainly have a lot of
people who feel that they have been um
missed
and that is important not just with
parking but for the rest of the council
business that we
want to encourage residents and
councillors and town councils to
participate in so i would like to set up
the about the consultation who was
missed out
and what we can do to
rectify that thank you chair
thank you very much councillor mclaren
councillor osborne
yep thank you thank you mr chairman
um i'd i'd just like to come up with two
points really uh on this debate
first of all as a baba district
councillor as well as a sudbury town
councillor
i do understand the concerns that have
been raised
however i'm very conscious of the fact
that the current three-hour free parking
is unsustainable for the council
the council must deliver an approved
balance budget for 2122
to ensure that we can continue to
provide essential services to our
communities and i'm very much
not wanting to see our essential
services uh uh be overridden by by
budget problems
i have seen emails both against and for
the proposal
from this i feel that uh a longer period
than the proposed half an hour would be
acceptable but not to continue with the
current three hours
also i would like to see an
implementation
date for revised charge to be made for
late 2021
or early 2022.
difficult decisions is a big part of
being a counselor and it is important
that we
base our decisions on facts rather than
assumptions
um many residents in sudbury and hadley
have have real problems with parking
near where they live
although not part of this discussion it
does impact on our car parks
i would like to suggest that a review be
undertaken to find solutions including
residents parking permits in our car
parks
could this be a recommendation please
thank you
fine we can bring that back if you would
do so during the recommendations phase
uh we'll move now to councillor uh jane
gould who's not present my apologies
councillor dawson
um i would um agree with most of what
adrian's actually said
um
i would like
to see more about factors about the
displacement of the traffic because this
clearly hasn't been considered at all in
hadley
um i think it should i agree with him i
think it should be deferred um until
basically after the comprehensive
strategic parking review
and i base that on the fact that
basically this decision was based on
reporting
um based on a low impact point it's a it
says quite clearly here it's a snapshot
study
it's based on informal
observations and there's no evidence or
analysis on any of the algorithms that
be mentioned
so we you know we're being forced to i
think it should be withdrawn really from
the budget
and be deferred as adrian has suggested
until after the comprehensive strategic
parking review when we've got proper
information to make a proper decision
can i just ask for a technical point can
this be withdrawn from the budget i'm
not certain it can since it has to be
debated by cabinet in the
february meeting
and it does form part of the budget
which of course yeah but if our
recommendation at the end of this is
that it should be deferred then i would
be i would be suggesting it needs to be
struck my point my point is i'm not sure
we have the power to defer an item in
the budget
because that's a budgetary process we
could make such a recommendation if we
wish to but we would also have to
consider as a scrutiny committee in our
budget consideration when we come to
that which is the next item we would
then have to be able to suggest
a budget alternative and a budget
alternative for 185 000 pounds seems to
me to be um somewhat untenable in real
in real terms okay so i'm just saying we
don't have the power to do that within
this paper
so i'll declare that
let's deal with the
with the report sorry can i finish it
actually i don't think you know you
think this is untenable but actually in
the big picture this is a very small
amount i mean in
you know it really is and um that's
what's
a bit of an issue here but um you know
we've got this comprehensive parking
review coming so why we're doing the
decision
prior to that taking place does seem to
be
you know complete madness
the parking review is actually part of a
statutory process yes but we should be
looking when we've got proper it says
quite clearly here it's a snapshot study
it's informal observation so how can we
make a decision uh you know officers
obviously uh councillor dawson we aren't
making a decision we are i don't know
but we're being asked to sit here and
scrutinize this and it's base sorry
could i it's based on
uh you know snapshots study you know how
can we make decisions on 200 000 on a
snapshot study and informal observations
it's not sufficient for the decisions
that need to be scrutinized here it
seems to me a little more than a
snapshot study but we'll move on that's
i'm only quoting what the officers have
actually put in the paper here they've
done it at a low impact point and
they've provided no evidence of any of
the algorithms which you know so you're
asking us to scrutinize it and there's
four points here which very clearly
should be addressed and they haven't
been okay thank counselor grandin
thank you chair
um i've been given a figure
for hadley that the deficit for hadley
car parks is 45 000.
and
well that's a lot of money it's actually
by way of things not a great deal of
money
um in in comparison with the whole it's
a big picture and um i think
we need to look at other ways of doing
this we certainly need to think of
postponement
um
i agree with council mclaren that um we
need further consultation well the while
the public
and it seems counsellors don't need to
be
consulted on
such matters
they should be
for good practice in my view
um
it was known before that this was a very
contentious subject certainly i've made
that clear to the chief executive and um
other leaders that this is a very
contentious subject
um in the district and certainly in
hadley and sudbury um so
it would be seen as good practice to
involve our public in in a consultation
and it certainly would have been nice as
councillors to have been consulted and
we were not
so that's um one point i would like to
make
and
regarding timing
i think um it's expected that the
country will have received their coveted
vaccinations by round about october
we need to allow
businesses
and
the public
the confidence to go out again
having had their vaccinations to sort of
face the new world if you like
and we need to allow
businesses time to recover
i think we should be looking at
six months after the time that the
government estimates that
all people that are elec who are going
to have their vaccinations have had
their vaccinations the government will
make a statement i'm sure
at a stage and say you know
90 of the public have now had their
vaccinations and that from then we
should say that is our
date
which i would guess will probably be
the following
new financial year
um
to implement our changes
those and then with regard to the fees
themselves
sudbury and hadley
should not be the same they have
different offers
and so that i think to be in the review
that is going to be taking place needs
to be given more consideration
um
and
um more thought as councillor dawson
said and i said previously to
displacement because i think that will
happen particularly initially
so thank you very much
thank you councillor brandon now i note
that uh the monitoring officer has a
point uh it may refer to something i
said earlier
um
emily would you like to comment at this
point
thank you chair and good morning
councillors and it is in relation to the
discussion you were having previously
about the route for approving the budget
and
where decisions can be taken around
deferring our items or removing them
from the budget
um so it's actually the cabinet that
proposes a budget to the full council
and the full council then takes the
final decision
so the overview and scrutiny committee
cannot refer
cannot resolve to defer this issue or
remove items from the budget
but you could make a recommendation
of that nature you can't take the
decision yourselves
you could also make recommendations that
the cabinet looks at further information
before taking its decision making its
proposed budget to the council and just
referring back to councillor dawson's
point about the additional algorithms it
could be that the committee makes a a
resolution to recommend that the cabinet
takes into account certain categories of
further information
um and if if i may i just want to kind
of pass a comment really on uh how this
debate is progressing and where you
might want to go in terms of
sort of coming to some recommendations
and i appreciate that this has this
issue has generated strong public
feeling
but the committee shouldn't be swayed by
that strong strength of public um
feeling
this pre-scrutiny is really about
um has the cabinet
taken into account all the relevant
information
have they been informed in their
decision have they
sought experts and
and other views on the issue before
taking that decision and that's really
where the cabinet should be thinking um
in terms of making any recommendations
is uh elements that you think may have
been missed from the cabinet's
consideration or from the report that's
being presented to the cabinet for for
consideration about this topic um i hope
that helps in some way chair thank you
thank you very much thank you very much
in fact it brings me to exactly what i
had in mind myself
um i had looked at this report
extensively and also all these
submissions that have been sent by
various people
stream of emails and
the
first thing that comes to mind is that
the sums involved at 50p a pound
and two pounds
are not large um i think that point has
to be made um
it was mentioned the use of hospitality
um i know very much
very easily what two pounds will
purchase in terms of liquid refreshments
in a hospitality area
um
does this defer deter people from
parking
now uh i've paid parking fees up and
down the country and most of them have
been a great deal larger than this
i don't think in my honest opinion that
a parking structure such as we currently
have with three hours free is
sustainable i don't see how it can
possibly improve the provision the
upkeep and the maintenance of our
parking provision
but the fee structure is obviously open
the question and suggestions have been
made if i had one i would make it's
apparent to me in part at least that
there is provision for an hour's free
parking in some places
and that for us to be charging after 30
minutes might be out of step with that
it'll just encourage people perhaps to
use one place where they get an hour
free in preference to our place where
they get half an hour free now i've
worked in town centers myself and i know
how much you can do in an hour and as
opposed to how much you can do in half
an hour you just need one queue in a
shop and you are stuck and you've lost
your half an hour
an hour i know i can do what i can do in
the lunch hour and i can do quite a lot
in a lunch hour with a little bit to
spare
so i would suggest that uh charging for
the first hour uh probably is not
appropriate in this instance
figures though of one pound and two
pounds
or even four pounds for all day
don't seem greatly out of step to me
that's just a general
viewpoint um
an hour free is actually generous and
and in fact achieves the objective if
the average stay is 64 minutes so we get
it down to 59 minutes
uh i suppose that would be something of
a step forward now as to the
differing
charges
and the differences between sudbury and
hadley i confess i don't have enough
knowledge of the parking offers and the
comparators i personally prefer
simplicity
i would like to see a sort of uniform
charge at baber but i can see why that
might not be possible
um
for example though i know chelman
distant pin mill a change to 50p an hour
i know that car park it's very small and
50p an hour is not a heck of a lot if
i'm honest to get to to go down to pin
mill um you know a pound for two hours
one pound fifty for three hours i think
we're gonna be short of 50 p's but there
you go
um
lavenam i know has its own arrangements
so
um my thinking is moving towards some
alteration
a modif modified suggestion
of something between option two and
options three in the paper
uh the principle of subsidized parking
is
one that is not
generally available
uh
somebody has to pay for these costs
regardless of
who uses them and a large number of
people who don't use parking in these
locations is going to be subsidizing
them through their council tax that's
unavoidable
and the question is of course how much
of a subsidy is can be borne by others
who don't get the benefit
i don't think the figures um are gross
out of all proportion in fact they're
incredibly cheap so i'm thinking that
looking at the recommendations because
we moved to them
that
a
comprehensive parking review is needed
it's something we should have done a
long time ago perhaps
the principles and the interventions in
appendix a do seem reasonable
where the issue seems to lie is in the
recommendation 3.3 which applies to
these actual charges
a residential parking permits seem
reasonable
and uh
the idea of
using a proportion and that is only a
proportion of the income generated from
chargeable parking for sustainable
travel
again seems to me only only too much in
keeping with our corporate plan
and with our aims as a council uh
particularly with regard to the
environment and
i'm sorry i know what cycling through
sudbury or walking through sudbury or
hadley is like
um congestion is a constant problem and
um you know
it it is it is and trust me on a bicycle
you're going to notice this thing
because those things can hurt you
all right um i'm that might seem trivial
and unimportant but we are trying to
move to a more sustainable agenda so
we've got lots of bits and pieces here
um
[Music]
i think we can now move if nobody has
any more questions cancer osborne you
still have your hand raised
as does councillor grandin but i'm i'd
like to propose that we will move
towards recommendations once we're
complete with this phase and councillor
dawson and councilman lvc i know not
councilmembers anyway debate about laven
because this is something that really
concerns me the fact that we've got to
and certainly like everybody if i go to
dedham a tourist site i would expect to
pay now i fully understand
you know we're looking at
why i know it's something to do with
their parish council
um but presumably there's mention about
a quarter million capital investment
how come they're
not being they've been left out i mean i
know claire arf is on the cabinet and
it's his ward well it's not it's not
under our control i think is the point
here um we we it is under control of the
parish capital does that mean that we're
not obliged to give any any sort of
capital investment for you know running
it at all i suppose
because they've got this honesty box
well
i i have to say that's up to them
i mean it's like we can't actually
interfere in the policies of ncp um but
sorry
but i can't even just clarify we in this
paper here it mentions about a quarter
of a million capital um are they are are
they are they self-financing out of
their parish honesty box
tarring enforcement etc i mean how's it
how's all that working then they can't
possibly paying for it
any answers
maybe you can mr chairman can i
interject here um lavenam is a
particular case on its own because it
has been
um in discussions with baber for
more than several months i would suggest
it's even more than 18 months um and if
i could invite um cassandra clements to
actually give you more background detail
on that
thank you
of course thank you so yes that's right
uh lebanon parish council i've been in
talks with baby for some time now about
taking over the full management of the
car parks and toilets within lavanam as
well as a number of other assets as well
i might add
whether that be public realm grass
cutting and there's some conversations
going on and with some some other assets
as well
so that's why this was left out because
we are hoping for that conversation to
come to a conclusion very quickly and
therefore it wouldn't fall within the
period of of the implementation of this
report
just to clarify the honesty box there um
because i asked this question when i
first came is for the toilets and not
for the car park
so it is for people using the toilets
it's used to help with the upkeep of the
toilets um but it absolutely on on
councillor dawson's point there um they
have raised funds themselves and they
have then also applied for caps for sale
funds as well for the adaptions to the
car parks and toilets that are happening
currently
okay
um have we any more debate to carry on
or do we would like to go to
recommendations councillor grandin i see
you raising your head
yes it's only that i'm concerned that
you might be moving to recommendations
that i don't actually fully support
well
we don't know we don't know what we've
got yet but what i was proposing to do
is to go through each recommendation in
turn
using the
cabinet recommendations as a model we
are not restricted or confined to those
and we can discuss each one in turn
would that be okay for you councillor
grandin
yes thank you and then those points can
be brought up at that time
so let's take let's take the overarching
one which of course is the very concept
of having
sorry could i just come back i'm
slightly because that's going to lead us
on a totally different direction to what
the three people here actually want
because they actually want to recommend
that it goes into the budget and goes
forward and the impression i'm having
here is all three of us want to have
this delayed and pushed back so
all three of whom uh
adrian myself and catherine so that was
quite a difference
i don't know that that assumption is
necessarily warranted yet because we
haven't had a chance to discuss
any proposals
with respect to sean uh mr chairman i'm
sorry i had to come in on this i am not
proposing a deferment of this i'm
proposing that we we alter the the dates
that's that's all it is
and i think i suggest
we get
for a long time now i suggest we get to
the recommendations uh as quickly as
possible and vote for it thank you let's
let's just go through some of the
recommendations we have potentially in
front of us now the first one is that a
comprehensive
parking strategy review be undertaken i
see no difficulty in that it's an
obvious thing to do it's what the
principle is
we might argue methodology we might
argue timing and the timing is the
question it will commence in quarter 21
22 quarter two now of course commence
doesn't mean it'll be finished it just
means it'll start
um delegation be given to the assistant
director again
that would be a normal process under
under our governance arrangements but
obviously we provide a steer for
officers and the cabinet provide an even
bigger steer
so i would suggest that 3.1
could potentially be changed to commence
in quarter 3
but i'm not sure it necessarily needs to
since the key word here is commence
any thoughts on that point members
does the date need to be changed or will
the word commence cover the issue
so when you refer to commence do you
mean the effects the commencement
review be undertaken this is a review
not the
actual implementation
there is a time scale in appendix b
which displays the various timings and
we would be able to would be able to do
the um
we would be able to adjust that although
i think frankly
the
officer the assistant director
having the authority given to them by
the cabinet on the basis of
recommendations made then would have the
option to
move things back so do we need to change
the date for commencement oh i agree
with you mr chairman no i agree with
chairman i agree so
3.1 as it is written
could stand and covers members concerns
in my view
now 3.2
the parking management principles and
interventions detailed in appendix a be
implemented with effect from the 1st of
july 2021
now those are the principles appendix a
is quite a lengthy document
but it does contain some specifics
and i think some of those specifics do
relate to the charging structure can i
can you confirm that um
cassandra that's correct yes so it is
the charging structure and the
investment in it to summarize it it's
the charging structure and the ongoing
investment needed in the car park so
really it's taken in one at the time we
weren't aware that the new strains of
kovid 19 were going to be quite so
serious and i suspect that
we've not it's been a moving target
constantly
and i suspect that it would not be
unreasonable that the
recommendation there be changed from the
first of july to some later date which
in effect is deferring the issue
um i don't know if one quarter would be
sufficient that would take us into the
autumn
uh which time as was mentioned by a
member earlier
we're hoping that the
vaccine rollout for the entire country
will be almost complete
any thoughts on that members
yes yes
can i um come in here by all means
council brandon
thank you chair
um
[Music]
first of all can i just mention
cassandra mentioned
investment in the car parks being tied
up in 3.2
i think it depends on what kind of
investment um
councilmember
um previously mentioned the railway walk
um car park
the kind of investment there
is
urgent because the whole thing is
crumbling away
so that kind of engineering type
investment would need to be looked at
separately from the kind of investment
such as signage and lines and that kind
of thing so i would request that those
two types of investment as are looked at
in as two separate issues okay so thanks
that's one thing i just wanted to
mention there simply because cassandra
mentioned investment as linked to part
of the implementation of 3.2 i mean
appendix um appendix a councillor is
after all a great long list of things i
don't think we want to pick it apart
because it mentioned that particularly a
moment ago
appendix a covers all those points
and i think that's one of those places
where officer delegation makes a great
deal of sense but the emphasis that
you're placing on that is important
on timing
i i would like to mention again
that
it it's no good
um having the implementation starting
just as people are having their
vaccinations we've got to allow
um our businesses to time to recover
we
we we have hit them as as a country with
all the lockdowns so much already we are
as a council
we've got the invest in hadley and the
invest in sudbury
um board set up that's meant to be
assisting businesses
and i sometimes wonder what is the point
if we're taking away one of the biggest
things that helps our local businesses
which is the three hours free parking
so
um
you know with regard to timing if we
have to introduce such measures or
measures
we need to give them time to recover
first and at least six months
after
the
vaccinations aren't completed would be
my suggestion i mean there are a lot of
a lot of suppositions baked in there
obviously and it's difficult to make
that can i make a suggestion then
because again words matter
that that read
that they'd be implemented
no earlier than
a certain date
and that the date is set somewhere
around the autumn that it reads be
implemented no earlier than subject
subject to changing circumstances
due to covid19
sorry could i come in
okay i i'm speaking with dawson and i'll
come to
yeah certainly was my business and i
understand quite completely all the
covid i think that's a bit of a red
herring completely
this needs to the date needs to be
implemented
after the comprehensive parking strategy
review is taking place if that's done in
the first quarter then we can do it
sooner if that parking review takes
place in 2022
that is when it needs to be implemented
but what we can't do
is recommend that this is implemented
you know bringing in covid is
it it's just not real what is the most
important thing is that this decision
um this is the parking management
principles and interventions come after
the parking strategy review it's got to
you know it's it's it's how long is the
review likely to take because well if
they do it quickly it says here in
quarter 2021
but if they you know
well that goes back to 3.1 here it's
very clear uh that's up to the cabinet
isn't it that the ball's in their court
it doesn't say that it does say commence
i just wondered how long the process
would actually take absolutely i i
covered this very briefly earlier so i'm
sorry if i i didn't go into enough
detail that absolutely your right chair
says commence
the average time that a survey or a
strategy like that takes to develop is
around a year and a half
yes so that's not really terrible well
you need the information
to make the decision to make the
decision you can't possibly
no i'm not so convinced of that i'll
make my point
sorry
can we just speak one at a time
we've got to look at the displacement
we've got to look at the timing we all
acknowledge that a tariff needs to be
applied i mean i accept that all of us
do
but this is all about you know there's
no point in do you know as i forget
doing the comprehensive parking review
if you're going to do all this it's just
a waste of time in effect councillor
dawson though it sounds as though you're
proposing an 18-month deferment and i'm
not sure
i'm well i think i think that should be
deferred yes if the parking review is
not completed
you can't make the decision without
having that report there with the
details this is being done it says quite
clearly on it's a catch it's a snapshot
it's a casual observation
i don't expect it's a casual observation
the report contains a great deal more
detail than any catalogue
well that's not what has been quoted in
here i've i've picked the words out
clearly as they've been put in here
um you need the information to to make
an informed decision and if you don't
have that detail
you know that's what we're here to
scrutinize for we are scrutinizing the
officer report now we are also of course
quite prepared to admit that um
delegated decisions by officers are very
much part of the process and
we are not talking uh it depends on
which way you're going there
there are
relatively small charges involved
enough of the principles um and
interventions detailed in appendix a
have been decided upon
i'm trying to find a work form of words
in this
recommendation that members will accept
as being reasonable under the
circumstances but i don't believe that i
could sir
are you saying you don't believe that's
acceptable i don't believe
deferring the decision effectively for
18 months is is
is feasible
review is if it's done after thank you
mr chairman exactly
as the cabinet member if everybody else
could let her speak
thank you um i did mention in my intro
that in all probability the current
report would be rewritten
because we would take on board what the
committee's recommendations are etc
and what tomorrow full council
recommend what recommendations come out
of that
but could i please remind counselors
that you sign you all signed up
unanimously
to the climate change and biodiversity
action plans
and this
policy
that we're trying to get approval to
implement will go some way
to addressing
our
co2 emissions
and help with biodiversity because it
will
not immediately granted
because rome wasn't built in a day but
it will provide with some revenue
to start looking at
walking ways
foot paths when i say a footpath i'm not
making meaning the actual physical foot
path but planning and directing routes
that walkers can take
through
cycle lanes
cycle parks
at the moment
cycles cycles are tied up to railings
both in hadley and in sudbury
you make you make an excellent point but
it's not advancing us any work
the monitoring officer has her hand
raised i wonder if you can contribute
anything here emily
thank you chair um i just wanted to
remind the committee that the debate
should be following the rules of
procedure
so we're getting into it quite a lot of
chewing and throwing of comments um and
i appreciate that you're allowing some
discretion around giving councillors
multiple opportunities to contribute but
we do have rules of debate and they
should be followed and it shouldn't be
interrupting and talking over other
members which is is what we are getting
at the moment
and chair we've been you've been
debating this item for two hours and 15
minutes
could i suggest that you take a short
adjournment
giving all members a chance to collate
their final thoughts on the topic and
then you come back with the intention to
either agree some recommendations or if
it's not possible to make a
recommendation that all the committee
can um buy into
then perhaps you just agree that your
comments from the debate will be
reported to council
and the council and
and then the cabinet thereafter can make
their own uh assessment of of the
entirety of the debate that may well be
terrific thank you very much
emily uh councillor mclaren then uh
councillor grandin uh or well actually
would you rather have that break right
now
can i just remember you were waiting
can i just make a comment chairman
um
we've got to be realistic about covid
and if we
keep bringing covert into our
discussions whichever committee we're on
we're in danger of paralyzing the action
of the council and i think it's
important that we progress
not including covid unless that is
important to the matter in hand thank
you chair
thank you obviously there are a number
of differing opinions on this and i
quite understand the reasons why
councillor grandin do you have anything
to wish you had to wish to add before we
go to a sort of smaller journey
i just have a question of cassandra um
can i ask what the point of a
comprehensive parking strategy review is
if
the decisions of this paper are already
implemented
of course thank you very much for the
question um i'll bring richard walker in
on this because i know that he has
managed a number of comprehensive
parking strategies
and this is just one element of those
but perhaps richard you could concisely
try and cover uh the list of what a full
strategy um covers i shall try and keep
it short because i can literally talk
for hours on this subject um so the
snapshot is a server that's done from
the current um is what happens what's
happening now and the actions that you
need to take now to prevent things
getting worse as they are as we know it
now
and the observations have
built up that picture so we know what's
happening now
the strategy is something that you'll
need to do in the future against the
timeline for the other interventions
that you'll make a bit further down the
line so we know we've got some visioning
and other things happening that are
planned
this strategy which will take 18 months
two years to get to a decision point
and then implement your policy for
things that will happen in future taking
regard of your visioning and and the
other uh developments that are going on
in each of the towns so the there's a
there's a looking forward element to the
strategy piece uh and planning for a
future policy but to see what's
happening right now on the ground which
is the report that's in front of you
so the word snapshot is perhaps a little
misleading it's not quite as cursory as
perhaps has been implied by some
interpretations all right members i
think we'll take a break now for 10
minutes while members consider how they
would like to approach the
recommendations if we are indeed to make
any or whether we just ask that all the
comments made in this meeting be noted i
would like to think we can come to some
form of recommendation based upon those
going to cabinet but i will note that
i'm fairly certain that cabinet will be
making changes that has already been
admitted right from the start of the
meeting
and i'm pretty sure the cabinet member
has paid very close attention to every
point we have made so we'll see you all
back in 10 minutes time at noon
and i'll let you get a cup of coffee and
comfort break
certainly chair members if you can
respond when i call your name thank you
um councillor dawson
president
councillor grandin
uh councillor mccraw
present
council mclaren present and councillor
adrian osborne presence that's all
presents sir
chair sorry
okay
that's don't worry about it
i have i've had other epithets used
against me
um
right we were at the point of whether
considering whether we could make
recommendations one of the principles of
scrutiny uh has always been uh in my
involvement on it to make
to add value
making wishy-washy
we ask the cabinet to consider
those sorts of recommendations carry no
weight whatsoever they can just say yeah
we've considered it we're not doing it
i don't believe that we should be doing
such a thing i believe we should be
making positive um statements
providing
an essence of what we've discussed
and giving the guidance that we believe
that we've done in our examination
nowhere else in council matters to do
reports receive such detailed scrutiny i
think we can see today and in fact we
could have been even more detailed but
be grateful we weren't
uh the point i'm making is that if we're
going to make recommendations they
should not be along the lines of
wishy-washy they should be clear and
firm and provide direction
otherwise or just to note our comments
again strikes me as a very wishy-washy
approach now i'd like if possible for us
to achieve some consensus here and to
find a place where we can achieve that
consensus
so if members would like to i would like
to ask members to maybe consider whether
the basis of the recommendations is
something that we can accept but it's
some of the detail
would that be a fair accepting of the
situation we'd know this has got to be
done it's a matter of timing it's a
matter of effects
it's a matter of the scale of charges
i've made one suggestion that the first
hour be free
um i believe that's in line with some
other thinking elsewhere um it's still a
better deal than anybody will get
anywhere else so over to you members um
i'd like somebody else to take on the
subject of the recommendations if they
would
counselor brandon
and councillor dawson
thank you chair
i
we've already had it established in the
report that 64 minutes is the average
stay
that means quite a lot of people stay
longer and obviously many less
i would like
we in hadley
so i'm saying this for hadley because i
think different rules might apply for
sudbury
um
would like to encourage people to stay
i would like two free hours parking and
for the inflammation date to be
six months after
the country decides or the government
decides that most people have had their
coded vaccination that's a little
nebulous but can i ask her i would
suggest that that would probably be
april 22
right that's a long way away all right
uh can i have comments on other members
on that suggestion please
i have to say i don't think two pounds
or two hours freeze is much different
from three and i don't think it
addresses the issues
um that's why i've suggested let's do
something different
i'm responding to your suggestion and
i'm asking other members to do the same
my response would be that i personally
would support one hour and i don't think
the date should be quite so far in the
future but i do think it should be uh
left to some discretion based on real
circumstances
so any other comments from members
caster grandin you've made your
suggestion i've responded with my
alternative suggestion can i hear from
other members please
thank you thank you mr chairman
i've already made my comments earlier on
and i i totally agree with with you on
on that recommendation that uh that two
hours would be just like having three so
it doesn't do anything i would go with
the one hour thank you
okay
counselor and you're happy with the uh
uh
not putting the date so far in the
future i think it's fairly clear that
cabinet will be doing that anyway
well guys that i should recommend that
they do so and i see councillor malvi's
in nodding her head councillor mclaren
yes um i would just support the hour um
in comparison across the country that
that happens elsewhere
and also i think september should be a
date perhaps that was agreed
for the
implementation as opposed to
a year ahead or whatever and and i would
add further to that that it should stay
it doesn't have to say with effect it
should say no earlier than september
that allows for changes in circumstances
i believe that covers the meaning behind
your student council mclaren anybody
else counselor
uh counselor dawson
you have your hand raised counselor
dawson
i i i do agree with the tariffs being
implemented in sudbury um they're happy
they've had their
um you know they've had their snapshot
study and the observations have been
done there
but i have to insist
i'm sorry you've dropped out there
councillor dawson
uh cassandra um your microphone's off
but your hand is raised
thank you i was trying to find an
appropriate point to jump in earlier on
this but couldn't couldn't quite get in
there i just wanted to dispel this issue
that the surveys and the research has
only been done in sudbury it's been done
in every single baby car park so the
same research has been done in every car
park there's been no difference thank
you council dawson you were saying
sorry am i backing again now you are you
you you're at the point of saying you
believe you agree with sudbury but you
think hadley's well i i i just sort of
feel
we it shouldn't be made on sudbury until
after this comprehensive parking review
that that's an 18-month process so i
don't know that well you can certainly
suggest it but i i don't know if anybody
else would support that
i'm afraid i couldn't
i've been quite frank about it
i don't think it's tenable um any other
members thoughts
i
i think that um september
is much too soon
um
vaccinations by then and i'm afraid
kovid is an issue um in relation to um
parking and high street businesses so
you know it is an issue the
recommendation would be potentially no
sooner than september
not
september
yeah and therefore therefore that that
allows
that
change of circumstances that might or
might not take place
but it doesn't
i'm looking for something we can agree
upon that provides us clear steer
to cabinet who bear in mind do not have
to accept our recommendations
if we make untenable recommendations
they probably won't
counselor dawson
i keep getting cut off here so i i
i i mean i've been very clear about it i
think it should be done after the
comprehensive parking review and i would
like to suggest that perhaps the
comprehensive parking review in hadley
is actually brought forward and in which
case um then we can get on with this
sooner okay but 18 months 18-month time
frame anybody else got any thought
hang on because we've got to be
independent here you've got to bear in
mind the impact of this we're talking
about only 45 000 and actually that
amount is very inconsequential when
you're looking
at 140.
i'm sorry councillor dawson then
councillor grandin to some extent
our job here as a scrutiny committee is
not and i did mention this at the start
we're not considering our ward positions
we're considering the paper as a whole
and we carry a wider responsibility
and that's what our job is in scrutiny
is and i would suggest that the points
on a hadley an award basis perhaps be
better made tomorrow at the council
meeting but our job is to scrutinize the
paper not not to uh to basically be too
parochial if you may no but
the option being put forward which is
being recommended is option two here
which is going to generate 400 thousand
pounds worth of income um hadley i mean
okay let's take pin mills
just to correct you councillor dawson it
would not be option two it would be a um
a hybrid between options two and three
as i suggested and in fact the
significant point is that it would cover
um the vast majority of the average stay
64 minutes 60 minutes i frankly i doubt
somebody's going to get round and slap a
ticket on you after four minutes um
particularly as i don't think we're in
that position yet as far as as far as
enforcement goes i'm just trying to come
to a point where we can find some
substantive sensible recommendations
that can be sent to cabinet or we just
send them uh a summary of everything we
said today but i don't think that
provides any likes or reason uh
councillor osborne
yeah thank you mr chairman i absolutely
agree with you here we just we just need
to uh to bring this forward in it as a
note i i should suspect because this
position between hadley and sudbury is
just is just uh
unattainable and um uh i i agree with
you that you know
when you look at it 18 months would be
another budget coming in
far too late and the amount of money
that we've already been told we're
losing 185 000
each year i'm afraid that that will be
out of pocket and the district council
would not be able to have a
and even a a a budget then that is uh um
budget is is a reasonable amount i'm
sorry but i agree with you mr chairman
let us get this thing sorted out either
as a note
noting for noting and and
the cabinet will
no doubt bring this to full council on
our tomorrow thank you well i think it's
fairly clear that um i'm going to make a
proposal and we'll see how that goes and
we'll see
what
turns out
my proposal would be the following that
3.1
um
can be amended to
the strategic parking review well it's
only a parking review it doesn't apply
um until we implement it so the
implementation we want this to start so
i don't see that 3.1 needs changed so i
would propose that 3.2 i don't believe
that needs changed
except to say that
except i'm going to finish except to say
that the date
should be no sooner than the 1st of
september 2021
this is my proposal that additional
parking controls our tariffs be applied
bloody bloody blah
not in accordance with option 2
but with um
a
option
two one so option two stroke three
variant
to include one hour free parking
with the exception with the exception
obviously of those places where it was
50 p an hour at german distance and so
on but for sudbury and hadley the basis
of one pound free an hour this is my
proposal we can discuss it and vote on
it but that's what i'm suggesting
subject to the statutory order process
and requirements for consultation i
don't believe there's anything wrong
with the rest of it
the 3.4 i don't see anything needs to be
changed there the principle of
residential parking permits is quite
reasonable and i haven't heard anything
to say that that shouldn't be done
that 3.5 again is a very reasonable
point and of course is inherent in the
entire purpose of the report and 3.6 to
resolve to delegate the decision to make
the changes in order to bring in the
agreed changes to the assistant director
for environment and commercial
partnerships so that appropriate actions
can be undertaken in a timely manner the
definition of a timely manner i think is
very open
and in fact it's going to be a matter of
interpretation anyway
so that's my proposal
um i hope the
governance officer has a note of those
and i would ask for a seconder
yeah i'll second that mr chairman
all right and can i just can i just add
to those recommendations you said to me
you said you spoke about the
permit parking in the car parks for our
residents could that be a
place
where it says in the middle lane car
park
um
are you suggesting others be included
are there other car parks because uh
from from where we are
uh there are a lot of residents with no
free parking because of the way that the
uh the terraced housing and there is no
parking except in the roads and they
have to park on the pavements etcetera
etcetera and therefore um if it could
cassandra could look at this uh in terms
of residence parking's uh permits within
the car parks
it would be a matter of requirement for
consultation anyway so i believe that
that point can be covered am i correct
cassandra
hello thank you chair it can be covered
yes um that would have been one of the
elements of the wider strategy so when
richard was talking about the future
looking at all uh permits across the
board would have been that which is why
we were specifically asked to look at
mill lane um at this point um
however if if that that can be a
recommendation going forward it can be
pulled out ideally it would be kept in
the full strategy review okay in the
middle lane car park sudbury
uh um with with further examination
to be undertaken in other car parks
would that suffice
yeah i'm i'm happy with that one mr
chairman you know that you have those
words further with further consideration
of other car parks excuse me tip which
where would you like me to add this um
after middle lane car park sudbury
you and adrian are driving through this
and actually
um coming
through
can we follow the rules of debate as has
been mentioned i'm making
can i ask you to be quiet for a moment
thank you
good
night could you ask
your please if you interrupt again i
will turn your microphone off
i'm trying to make a point here by
making a proposal with a seconder
if it doesn't if it falls it falls but
we need to get somewhere and i've
already made my points
that's all i'm going to say on the
matter
councillor osborne
uh and council and henrietta you were
asking about where that should be
inserted
under the
modified proposal from councillor
osborne which i'm happy to agree with
i'm suggesting it's a mill lane car park
sudbury for overnight stays
with consideration of other car parks
i think that's absolutely right
statutory order process and the
requirements for consultation contained
in the recommendation the reason the
reason for bringing that out although
they've identified the mill lane car
park the two other car parks which uh
relate to areas of parking uh closer to
the
um center
means that those particular terraced
housings cannot park
in their own uh thing overnight and they
they need a part a permit to park in
those other car parks okay that's fine
that's perfectly reasonable and then
finally 3.6 to and i'm happy to accept
that modification and we'll include it
in my proposal to resolve to delegate
the decision to make the changes to
parking orders in order to bring about
etc etc a timely manner again i don't
see anything uh controversial in that
whatsoever that is a natural part of the
officer delegation that is necessary to
carry this process out
so we have a proposal and we have a
secondary now we are entitled to ask if
there is any counter proposal
councillors grandin and councillor
grandin
um
i would
like my counter proposal to be the one
that i
issued at the beginning of this
discussion please
which would be
which would be two hours free parking
and if sudbury feel they wanted
alternative time that would be fine
and um
to to implement six months
following the
time when um the public
the majority of the public have been
given their vaccinations okay so which i
assume to be
april 22. all right so you'd be
proposing uh that the uh minimum charge
be
a modified option one uh sorry option
two three with a minimum charge of two
sorry three hours two three hours not
one three
hour so two three hours would be the
change made there
and that the implementation not take
place till what time
i i
six months after the majority of the
population have been vaccinated which i
am assuming will be april 20 22. it's a
bit difficult to make that assumption at
the moment
um i don't know if we can include that
in the wording can you find a form of
wording that you think would be
satisfactory please ask emily or
henriette to help please yep any
thoughts thank you
so far have that hardly have two
hours free parking and alternative
timing uh be considered for sudbury and
that the implementation date is six
months after the majority of population
have been have been vaccinated against
the covin-19 pandemic
may i ask if um councillor dawson would
be happy with those um proposals yes i i
would second that
okay i was saying that and if there's an
issue with the uh i'd like this on
record that
um if there is an issue with the covid
depending if the comprehensive parking
strategy review becomes sooner than the
end of covid then i'm quite happy for
that to be brought forward
so let's say if kovid went until next
septe you know it goes on for much
longer if the comprehensive review is
completed before that
um then i would be happy for it to be
brought forward the amendments so we
have a counter proposal um
the monitoring officer has her hand
raised
thank you chair um i would actually
recommend altering the time condition on
uh the proposal that's been proposed and
seconded um i think the proposal or the
proposal the counter proposal um from
catholic uh councillor grandin and uh
councillor dawson um i think it's
difficult for the committee to use a
time constraint that's out of your
control
and also is is very unspecific
um i my recommendation would be that you
use the um
the parking strategy as your point in
time so
after the completion of the wider
parking strategy and then what you could
say is you could say something like um
and taking into account um the current
economic climate um following the
recovery of uh from covid19 or something
similar so you're reflecting that you're
you're considerate of the business needs
in the locality um but moving away from
the very uh kind of undefined uh period
of time i'm very happy to take your
advice what whatever you advise within
that and does councillor dawson agree a
second year i think that's what i've
said all along maybe i've not made
myself clear
the decision it should be done after the
comprehensive parking strategy review
which is i think what you're saying
emily isn't it agreeing yes can i ask
well
sorry
can i finish
i think that's what i've been saying
and with catherine all along
i'd be happy with that um
proposal
can i ask you to
have one before the other yes sorry i
asked the governance officer if she's
able to put that into the voting system
on modern gov or at least something
along those lines
that is clear that this is the counter
proposal we'll be voting upon first
yes chair uh we might just need two
minutes um can i just read that second
count proposal up again just to make
sure we got the right wording and that
the monitor officer agree what i have um
taken down
um that hadley have two hours free
parking and an alternative time will be
considered for sudbury and take into
account the current economic climate
caused by the covet 19 pandemic
is that along those lines um
monitor officer that you would like me
to write this down
is that like i said a suitable way for
for expressing this
if i can come in to chair um
i think the word
needs to make reference to the
review the comprehensive parking
strategy review yeah it needs to be
that's the time scale
okay and this should be implemented
after that
okay
do
much if the governance officer could let
us know when she has that up on the
attendance and voting section
[Music]
um
excuse me will that be read to us again
please before before it's on the
um
yes i would need to read it again
because i'm slightly confused at the
moment so okay so i'm just i'm sorry
that it takes so long but it we have a
lot of people speaking across each other
um so um so i have so let's just agree
on the first part that had to have two
hours free parking and alternate time be
considered for sudbury
we agree on that
is that correct
and then sorry wouldn't mind repeating
that sorry that hadley that hadley have
two
hours
free parking
and that an alternative uh time ming or
time a free parking time be considered
for sudbury is that right
no can i just shall i say yes the first
part the first part's correct
and then reference to 3.2 the parking
management principles
and interventions
detailed in appendix a
will not be implemented until after the
comprehensive parking
strategy review
that's catherine's
amendment
are you happy with that katherine
yes
sorry i'm completely lost now sorry okay
we have three points
maybe maybe take a short break
is it possible to take a very short
break just to get this sorted out let's
do that 3.1 remains unchanged is that
agreed in your amendment yes
3.3.2 contains the wording that
counselor dawson came up with regarding
the implementation taking place after
the completion of the comprehensive
parking strategy review
3.3 contains reference to a minimum
charge instead of being uh sorry minimum
free parking for free parking being
instead of it being one pound
sorry one hour throughout it be two
hours in hadley
and possibly different in sudbury
and then 3.4 3.5 and 3.6 remain
unchanged is that correct councillor
grandin
that would be correct thank you does so
basically you have alterations to three
point one
no you don't three points yes you do
because
three
yeah 3.2 and 3.3
correct
this is the difficulty with the the um
modern gov system it has to be written
in in exactly the format that you are
voting upon
uh we could also chair just have you
reading those uh recommendations again
and just wrote as you have read them
chair
okay let me just make sure my
understanding of councillor grandin's
proposal is that the parking management
principles and interventions detailed in
appendix a b
not implemented until the comprehensive
parking strategy review
has been completed
yes
fine that's at 3.2
effectively 3.1 and 3.4 and 5 and 6
don't matter we're looking at 3.2 and
3.3 that's all
so three points expansions are two hours
yeah 3.3 mentions two hours
free parking in hadley
yeah and
the figure for sudbury to be determined
is that correct
that would be correct so you can use
them are you happy with that councillor
dawson
yes i would suggest an hour for sudbury
to make it simple
all right let's say two hours for hadley
and one hour for sudbury would that be
your suggestion yeah no that's i think
that's gonna be determined
yes let me see that power management
principle and intervention detailed
appendix b be inter implemented until
the comprehensive parking strategy
review has been completed that's
3.2
and that additional parking controls or
tariffs be implied to district car parks
in accordance with option 2 table 3
paragraph 6.3 of the report
to include 2 hours free parking in
hadley and wow's free parking in sudbury
subject to the state
sorry no i didn't agree to the one hour
in in sudbury
that was councillor dawson's suggestion
so what we'll do
be determined if you don't accept it it
stays as to be determined
thank you
if councillor dawson was still prepared
to second that
yes i am prepared to second it i would
just like to mention catherine there
that we ought to perhaps take into
consideration
um
the views oh damn it well i think i
think we have to come to some conclusion
on this this camera
i'm happy to go along with that i mean
that that's fine if you wanted to see
if it's ready to vote upon
yes you'd open up your voting screen
on modern gov those who are unable to do
so will have the opportunity
to make a manual verbal vote i don't see
it up yet
i have just started the vote check
that's it
it would say as read by the uh
governance officer i hope the committee
is happy with that i'm happy to read
them again the recommendation
so we go to the blue line click on that
and you have a possibility of voting for
against abstaining or declaring a
conflict of interests if you could make
your vote and then confirm it
there are two confirmed buttons to press
and this is the counter proposal not the
original proposal
so
what can i just confirm so i'm not
signing the wrong thing what do we have
in front of us
is your counterpart
thank you
excuse me care oh are we allowed to ask
for a recorded vote
the principal the principal in a
committee of only five
um would require all of us to do so and
i i don't
i think that well maybe
maybe emily can inform us of that maybe
three
it's three thank you chair it's it's
actually too late to request a recorded
vote because the vote has commenced
however
individual councillors can request that
their vote is recorded
oh thank you
chair
may i just go back
may i just go back to the vote please
yes let's go back to the vote okay it
appears everybody had voted except
councillor grandin now council grandin
would you please cast your vote to me
i haven't voted either
no that's
sorry sir council dawson i do apologize
yes but as i don't have it in front of
me am i voting uh for the amendment or
for against uh the original proposal
for the amendment we do this again okay
i'm voting for the amendment
you weren't your fault uh is that clear
yes chair so
everybody has voted now
and we have two votes four and three
votes against
okay so we now revert back to the
original proposal
um which was 3.1
as written
3.2
uh
no sooner than first of september
3.3
with the proviso that
one hour free parking be provided with
the exception of places like german
distance where the 50p an hour is
reasonable but it's hardly in sudbury a
basis of one hour's free parking be
applied i think those are the only two
places affected so that's sufficient
3.4 3.5 and 3.6 remain unchanged from
the original recommendations
so if that can be covered we would now
need to put that up on the screen as the
original proposal
yes chair one moment we need to add
another vote here uh mandy can i ask you
to add another vote to this um
uh item please
thank um
it should be there now henriette thank
you so the vote is there now chair yep
just need to turn it green don't we it
is
ah here we go i'm just putting into
progress now this is the original motion
proposed by myself and seconded by
councillor osborne
four against abstain or conflict of
interests
members would like to vote
cancer dawson may i ask for your vote
please yes i'm against
right we have completed the vote
and we have
just double take three four
and two against
okay
i will so report
to council but i will report the
minority opinion
um as a matter of good practice um
because i believe that's only the fair
thing to do
now this recommendation goes to cabinet
not to council but it's only fair that
council have that for tomorrow's debate
cabinet of course are free to ignore us
or alter anything we say but we will
have provided
some idea of the background and we have
actually worked on providing concrete
proposals so i thank members very much
for that
now i'm mindful that we've been at this
now for three hours and i'm wondering if
members would like to have a half hour
adjournment
in order to consider the budget um at
say just after one o'clock or whether
you'd like to carry on
can i hear from members councillor
osborne
oh thank you mr chairman
just um to remind um
those that are on the um uh
meeting at four o'clock so
i'm just hoping that uh we're not going
to go faster
briefing i believe has been cancelled
all right maybe i'm wrong maybe that's
tomorrow i'll just check
but i believed that there was a briefing
that i just saw the other day
that had actually been
yes
jmb on an environment i believe it was
cancelled just the other day
oh excuse me chair excuse me we're
talking about a different meeting chair
apologies talking about chairman's
briefing oh apologies
well hopefully we'll be done hopefully
we'll be done rather quicker than on
this item
um
take any longer i haven't i actually
have a 2 30 meeting um
with john robinson at
um which i've already do we want to
carry on or do we believe we can
go through the final item the budget and
the housing revenue account in the
course of say an hour
i'm just asking if members would like to
have a short adjournment for half an
hour to get a rest or have a bite of
lunch or whether you would like to carry
on right now
well
not hearing any um counselor grandin
i'm i'm happy either way but i would
have to leave at 2 30 whatever well
we'll
mclaren
sorry
um i think we should continue okay fine
let's continue
so we'll now uh
come to bos 21
draft general budget for
2021-22 and the four-year outlook
i'd now like to invite councillor ward
the cabinet member for finance to
introduce report bos stroke 20 stroke 2.
thank you chair
i'm pleased to introduce support bos 22
for the 2021-22 general fund budget and
four-year outlook
there is again uncertainty this year
over the core funding that will be
available over the medium term
the three-year comprehensive spending
review has been delayed and a one-year
review was published in october focusing
on continuing continuing the response to
covert
the financial support for curved
pressures will continue into the first
quarter of next year
as will the rural services delivery
grant
additional support businesses announced
at the beginning of the month is also
being provided
the government has confirmed that the
fair funding review business rates
review and business rates reset have
been deferred yet again
details of these and other features of
the spending review are provided in
paragraph 418 of the report
the recently announced provisional
financial settlement for
to 2022 does give us additional funding
of 724 000 pounds
the details of the settlement are
provided in paragraph 419 to 422 with
table 1 providing a summary of the
financial impact
the financial impact of code this year
has been consistently evolving and our
initial very worrying assessment has
been ameliorated by very generous
government support
a summary of the impact is provided in
paragraphs four five to four ten
the key numbers were presented in last
month's quarter two monitoring report
and are summarized again here
keeping track of this has involved a lot
of work for the finance team my mid
software finance portfolio colleague
john whitehead and me
we have a sound medium term financial
strategy for the next four years that
responds effectively to the changing
funding landscape for local government
the strategic aims principles and
approach are set out in section six of
the report
along with a list of our achievements
during the current year
in summary and this is no change in
recent years we must continue with our
efforts to become self-sufficient
through maximizing our income streams
continuing to make efficiencies and
productivity savings and also continue
to find new ways of working
the continuing delay to the
comprehensive spending review does make
our four-year outlook more uncertain and
given that this was already challenging
for us this is a worry
the general fund budget requires 431 000
pounds or 52 of the anticipated 2021 to
22 new homes bonus receipts which will
enable us to transfer the rest of the
new climate change and biodiversity fund
details in new homes bonus funding are
provided in sections 86 to 810
of the report
funding assumptions are shown in
paragraphs 8 11 to 8 14 with the four
year forecast included in table six
for 2021 to 22 we will again be
increasing council tax at the maximum
level allowed without requiring a
referendum which is five pounds per year
or two point nine six percent for a band
e property and we have built in the same
increase for the three years following
the annual council tax for bandy
property will now be 173 pounds 86.
there is also the assumption of a 1 tax
base increase but for 2021 to 22 this is
reduced as a result of more use of the
local council tax reduction scheme
because of covert and also a lower
collection rate
the net effect of this is that we are
only forecasting a total council tax
increase of 39 000 pounds
table 7 at paragraph 816 provides a
summary of the budget showing the net
cost of service income and funding
compared with the previous year
although we are currently predicting a
surplus of 711 000 pounds for 20 20 to
21 but there is still a lot of
uncertainty regarding this and also 404
000 pounds for 2021 to 22 these should
be seen in the context of our medium
term outlook which i will address in a
moment
at this point i would like to mention
that we are forecasting a total of 2.2
million pounds from our cifco
investments an increase of 424 000
pounds on 2020 to 21
totally vindicating our investment
strategy which has ridden the covered
storm and is providing much needed
reliable income
the 2021-22 budget setting process has
again seen line-by-line budget
challenges to identify savings but the
cabin cabinet has also had to make some
difficult decisions
in addition to improving the council tax
increase which i will summarize now
we are increasing the garden waste
collection fee by 2.50 per annum we are
suspending the under 70s under 17's free
holiday swimming for a year saving 38
000 pounds we are relocating our
customer access point in sudbury saving
30 000 pounds
and lastly although not finalized yet
obviously given the preceding debate
here we will be introducing very modest
short-term parking charges as the
subsidy we're providing to our car parks
is no longer sustainable or justifiable
and they must become cost neutral
we will need to review the parking paper
in the life
suggestions and recommendations from
this committee and potentially also
council tomorrow but any change from
what has been proposed will impact the
forecast surplus 2021 to 22.
as stated earlier we are forecasting a
budget surplus of 404 000 pounds the
overall budget gap for the three years
from 2022 to 23 is described in sections
824 to 827 and amounts to a cumulative
deficit of 1.77 million pounds
further significant income or savings or
both will be needed to address
the this levels are detailed in
paragraph 7.2 table 3. we will use 381
000 pounds from earmark reserves just
for specific service expenditure but
this will be offset by some transfers in
most nodes will be the 404 pounds budget
surplus
from new home's bonus receipts into the
new climate change and biodiversity
reserve
this means that we are able to increase
our reserves by a modest amount in 2021
to 22 although the transformation fund
will be slightly lower
the capital program has set out in
appendix a and the plan spent for 2021
to 22 is 3.1 million pounds the
financing for this is shown in the
second table in the appendix the major
differences from this time last year
are that we will have completed our
cifco investments by the end of the
current financial year
and the bellevue capital investment is
no longer required now that the hotel
project will not take place
in summary we are currently in a good
financial position with a healthy level
of reserves and helped by the funding we
have received from the government to
mitigate the financial impact of covert
however as i have said the medium term
challenge is still significant as we
strive to become self-financing over the
next three years
and i do have
members of the finance team here to
assist with any questions should the
members of the committee have them thank
you chairman
thank you very much council award for
your introduction uh we have both
catherine steele and melissa evans
available to answer questions as well
so i'll now ask if members have any
questions um each member in turn uh
starting with councillor grandin
any questions councillor
[Music]
grandin thank you
um
i
understand the seriousness of our
situation
um
i have a slightly frivolous question
actually um at the moment
um but i i
would like if i may come back with
further questions later
um
why
have we why are we only putting the
brown bin charge up by i think you said
two pound fifty
um i think that's um a discretionary
purchase
and it's an excellent service and i
don't think people
users um
decide whether to have a brown bin or
not based on
you know
on price
if it was to go up by
say five pounds it's not going to put
people off having the brown bin because
it's such a good service and for those
that have it
a necessary service and a five-pound
increase over the year isn't going to
it will be
good good further income for the council
but wouldn't stop
users
buying into that service
so um why have you chosen such a low
not the normal type of question i
understand but why have you chosen such
a low increase on that please
we we looked at this um uh in the
context of rises in this service that
taken place last year and and earlier
we have to make sure that we
increase
in line with what is reasonable for the
service um it is not the first time
we've been increasing this particular
cost and also we're looking at um
comparable charges for this service um
at other councils as well and we felt
that two pound 50 bringing the the total
including the administration fee up to
around 60 pounds per annum
does make sense but you're right uh
councillor brandon it is excellent value
for money the uptake is increasing year
on year it is a discretionary service
like car parking and the principle that
the user pays is established for this
and quite um happily accepted by those
users
but um we felt that 2 pound 50 was was
the right um level at this this stage
thank you council award is it designed
just to add to be cost neutral uh to
encourage uptake
uh no it's uh it does make us a surplus
a substantial surplus okay fine thank
you very much um next question from
council mclaren please
if you have one yeah i have i have
um
my questions uh john relates to page 47
of your report
which was
6.6
i was interested in the diagram at the
bottom
um
in terms of review of services
we know that the public realm is coming
in house
we know that's already been agreed
um
are there any other services that we
could bring in house being considered
we haven't identified any others at the
moment the public realm is is obviously
the major one it was up for review and
we wanted to
standardize
the way that was operated at both
councils um but we haven't looked at
anything else at the moment okay and my
second question is about the use of
external consultants that are used in
the council has there been any review of
that and um
yeah we used this thought of we use
external consultants where we where it's
necessary where we don't have the skills
internally um an example as you were
discussing this morning on parking and
we've brought in richard walker from
from essex because he has the necessary
expertise to help us with that
we've also brought in external
consultants to help with our visioning
work for for sudbury um and to look at
options for hamilton road and bellevue
these are people that have those
specific skills and we can't possibly
support um having individuals with those
skills as as permanent members of of
staff and so we bring in the expertise
as and when necessary so you think that
all the consultants we've been using are
actually relevant to our our
performance as a council
uh yes they've been absolutely necessary
for the work that we've needed to do
that we have a lot of plans particularly
around economic development in our two
towns and um the
the use of these consultants has been
necessary to um
promote and
progress these plans without them we
wouldn't have been able to do that
thank you john thank you chair
my
microphone there i do apologize uh any
question councillor dawson do you have
any question
um yeah there's just one that i was
looking at the service charge i'm just
interested in this for endeavor house
um because in the commercial market
you know
rental incomes have gone down and our
service charges for endeavor house are
going up 43 000
um subject to discussions with suffolk
county council
and obviously with the caveat people
aren't actually in the building
so i would be expecting to see
considerable savings there and at least
a minimum you know reduction in rent
there i just wonder whether
bargaining position here they need
tenants in that building and we're
looking for savings and it strikes me we
could make quite a lot there and that
doesn't seem to have been reflected i
don't think in the figures here it says
there's going to be an increase of 43
and it should be quite the opposite
in endeavor house we entered into an
agreement with suffolk county council
about three three and a half years ago
now for endeavor house um i will have to
defer i think to catherine for the
specific answers around the service
charge there um as i do not have that
myself
thank you councillor ward if it's okay
if i come in chair um yes this this
this was a planned increase as council
of ward said when we entered into the
agreement with suffolk county council
over three years ago now there was
always going to be an increase in the
service charges but the ongoing
discussions that the chief exec is
having with uh southern candy council
are in relation to the changes that have
happened you know more recently
obviously the building being closed for
a prolonged period of time or access to
very limited numbers does mean that the
overheads that the county council has
incurred should be reduced as a result
of of that so say the conversations are
ongoing
and hopeful that we will see a reduction
in what it was supposed to go up by
but there are obviously still some fixed
overheads and we are in a lease
agreement so
we have signed a contract for that space
in endeavor house
thank you very much catherine uh
councillor osborne
any questions
i'll move on then to well myself
actually um i don't have any questions
at this point if i think of anything i
will bring it up
i'm sorry mr chairman uh there you are
cancer osborne yeah i'm trying to unmute
um now i haven't another questions at
the moment i'd just like to say that
that this subject has
been the topic of
most of the forums that that catherine
and her team have looked at and uh i'm
i'm in support of her i think they've
done extremely well to
to pull these uh
these things around which looked a bit
desperate at times when as you've
already stated we can't we cannot uh
have crystal ball to say that this might
not get worse or it might not get better
or it might will get better i hope but
uh there you go but uh yeah thank you
catherine and your team thank you
i just want to ask councillor ward uh
one thing because i think this is
probably a decision made at that level
is that i notice we have um
a 404 k surplus forecast for this year
um that's achieved using new homes bonus
uh section one for section 31 grant
rural service delivery grant
and a figure not dissimilar to 404 381k
from our reserves and
i i realize it's not nice to cut things
finer but was any consideration given to
maybe not using the reserves and having
an even smaller surplus or did we prefer
to leave ourselves a little bit of
leeway and felt that we could risk the
reserves i just wonder what the thinking
was behind that
that those reserves are earmarked for
specific service areas and the money has
been taken out to to support um those
specific service areas um
and uh
we
obviously with the new homes bonus that
that is something that is is reducing
every year but um we have got that
surplus this year we have got the
climate change and biodiversity
commitments we do need to be able to put
money aside to
meet those commitments in the years to
come so it made sense to to put that 404
thousand pounds into that new reserve
catherine did you want to add anything
more to that
just in terms as you've quite rightly
said council award that the withdrawals
from reserves are for particular
pieces of work one example is
homelessness we get money from the
government on an annual basis that we
put into a reserve and draw down on it
when we need to according to what's
happening in that particular service so
say that they are particular um service
areas rather than just a general balance
that's fine that was the point i was
trying to draw out that is not exactly
just taking from a lump sum of reserves
these are earmarked thank you very much
uh councillor grandin you have a
question
thank you claire um this may be the
question for um our environment um
cabinet member but um the 88 000
increase in vehicle running costs due to
moving to a new um
fuel
um could you tell me whether
this will get to a stage of being cost
neutral i'm not sure how these things
work because that seems a lot of money
to spend i know we are trying to be
carbon neutral but can you tell me um
you know whether this is going to be a
one-off cost and that it will eventually
make us money
as as a
clear clearly i'm not an expert in this
area but please
um
a cost neutral thing in the end please
no i can answer that uh councillor grand
and the the cost there is simply because
of the price differential between diesel
and hvo um
based on the the uh the current price
differential projecting forward
obviously if that changes then that 88
000 will will change
but it's not a one-off
thank you
this would be a consequence of our
environment policies
yes yeah i mean um climate change
obviously
climate mitigating climate change is
always going to cost nobody's ever said
it was going to be a free ride
um
but we can't just uh measure this in
terms of uh the money uh we have to look
at the uh uh the savings in in carbon
emissions and and that's the the
principal driver here so um uh that
that's that's what it will cost it's
going to save us a substantial is one of
the well it is the single biggest thing
that we can do to reduce our carbon
emissions
and um and we have to pay for it
i have a small correction to make when i
was looking through the papers i noticed
and it might be one something that could
be addressed before this is brought to
council in that in section seven marked
reserves
we have several seven point one seven
point twos and seven point threes or two
of them and the numbering there needs
attention uh just to correct it before
it's uh seen in public again yes yeah we
are aware of that
that's fine i thought it was probably in
hand uh are there any further questions
from members in which case could you use
the raised hand function
and i will also invite if any members
present who are not in the overview and
scrutiny committee would like to ask any
questions abby welcome to to take those
questions and direct them to the
appropriate person councillor dawson
i was just wondering whether catherine
could still perhaps could give us a bit
more detail about the investments with
schroders and ubs
and the returns on these
as outlined in the
context here
can you hear me
yes thank you councillor dawson yes i
was just taking myself off of mute um
those investments are still paying
positively to the councils so um i
haven't got the details in front of me
because we don't take the details
through to
the joint audit and standards committee
and they have got the draft treasury
management strategy going to their
meeting next week
but all of the investment funds that
we're currently holding are providing a
reasonable return back to the councils
so um despite what's happened over the
last um sort of 10 months nearly a year
now they are still providing income
returns which is obviously helping
baby's budget position
because what slightly um bothered me
with this is we have asked i think now
the last five years is if we could sort
of have a summary because when i look at
this at the figures for these some of
these my understanding is they aren't
doing quite so well but it's kind of
really difficult for us you know to tell
by looking at these figures because
we're clearly not familiar with them
and i just
i'm just
wondering whether we're ever going to
get that summary that's been requested
year after year to help us
um perhaps uh scrutinize this a bit more
closely because i don't feel i can
looking at these figures here or from
the where we're investing
i might actually be in a position to
help you there councillor dawson
yeah amazingly enough councillor
mclaren myself no seriously councillor
mclaren and myself both sit on joint
audits and standards and um and we do
look at the medium term uh financial
strategy which i think is where this
comes from and in fact at our last
meeting and our subsequent one we did
heavily question uh the returns on these
investments uh the most significant
point out of our last examination of the
medium-term financial strategy was that
the returns were holding up remarkably
well
considering the kovid 19 environment
council award made reference to the
returns being uh obtained from sifco but
in fact um the treasury management team
have done an excellent job uh and uh uh
audit and standards commented upon that
at the time and of our last meeting and
as has been said we may be meeting very
shortly to look at the latest iteration
of that so if that provides any any
assurance to you i mean i've been on
audit and standards for a few years now
and uh starting to get a feel for it um
and and it's surprising how solid
the returns have been
in very difficult circumstances
and tomorrow council we will be debating
the half-year position on treasury
management so um there'll be a lot more
information provided by the chair of
audit and standards then
councillor mclaren you have a point to
make uh just to support what you said
chairman about the audit and standards
committee at the last meeting i did
raise with officers uh the matter of
ethical investing and
catherine
still assured us
that
it was under consideration by the
financial team
so that
in terms of the environment i think
ethical investment is
you know a good consideration thank you
thank you councillor mclaren um i'd like
to ask if any of members present have
any questions that would be those
members who are not on the overview and
scrutiny committee if you'd like to use
the raised hand function that would be
fantastic
in the absence of any questions
i think we shall move to debate um
i'll now open the item up um we can do
this in the order i've got here which
starts off with councillor mclaren or of
course we can just do it as we wish by
raising hands
anybody wish to contribute to the debate
all right well i'm going to start it
then
um
obviously this is not the first time
many of us have seen the budget we go
through it several times in briefings
and other meetings this is my third or
fourth
trot through it and i have to say i was
pleasantly surprised by this year's
budget um
the recommendations are in line with
what we've previously done and we had
feared earlier in the year uh a whopping
great deficit
and we're not facing that now um we've
made jokes in the past
about rabbits being pulled out of hat
and at one point it was
intimated to us that there wasn't any
hats this year and yet again um
catherine and melissa and the team have
pulled together a budget that we can be
happy with for this year
with noting of course that there is a
deficit forecast for the next two years
and those impact those impacts and those
issues are not going to go away but that
might be a tale for another day
but as much as can be done has been done
so i was just very gratified by what is
relatively speaking a fairly neutral
budget it contains the things you would
expect
council tax does have to go up but it is
at the the lowest level that one might
reasonably expect it's the maximum we
can do but it's not a huge percentage
being just under three percent and i
would point out that that uh only
describes ten percent of people's
council tax i took a lot of time on this
subject seventy-five percent of council
tax after all goes to the county council
and about thirteen percent goes to the
police and crime commissioner
and about ten percent although we're the
collecting authority of near ten percent
of the total council tax is to the
district council
um and a fraction of two or three
percent might go to your parish councils
or your town councils a bit more for
towns but
all i was going to say is i commend the
team um
i think it's an excellent budget under
the circumstances it's an astonishing
budget
i would be quite happy to propose
the recommendations with one proviso
that we do make note that uh our
recommendations regarding the parking
matter will have an effect on the budget
and that should be included
with some form of wording perhaps with
the exception of changes recommended to
the parking charging
uh but i'm happy to propose that the the
motion uh available to us which is 3.1
which will be going to the cabinet and
3.2 that the draft the general fund
budget is increased to a council tax of
five pound per annum
10 p a week for a band e property
equivalent to two point nine percent six
percent to support the council's overall
position i can see no reason not to do
that quite frankly anything else would
be nitpicking at a time when we can't
afford to nitpick
casa osborne
thank you mr chairman your hive um
i'm happy to second your uh your uh
approval of that and uh obviously uh
hope that uh
we can continue with our with our good
uh investments uh et cetera et cetera
thank you
council award did you have something you
wish to say
uh yeah if you don't mind it's just
about rabbits in hacks actually um
you've got to remember that
um
with the situation with kobe we could
have been in a very very difficult
position
if the government hadn't been generous
and put in a huge fat bunny in the hat
i couldn't possibly comment council
award but i don't i understand your
reasons for doing so
um
i think i'm pleased that uber support
was available and uh i wasn't expecting
it in such um
[Music]
mostly munificence okay so uh any
comments any debate the members wish to
have or do you wish to proceed to the
vote any counter proposal
[Music]
do members wish to proceed to the vote
with that provision that we uh alter
that with the exception of the
parking matter previously debated
that we put forward that in 3.1 that
would be we forward 3.1 and 3.2
more or less as they are presented to us
we have a seconder can i ask the
government's officer if the vote can be
prepared on modern gov
yes chair um may i just uh sorry
was the council osborne who seconded
your proposal chair
thank you
chair may i just say that the audio and
scrutiny committee recommend
recommendation 3.1 and 3.2
in the report to cabinet with the
exception of the parking matter which
has been debated at today's meeting yes
and that should properly appear in
recommendations 3.1 since 3.2 is
unrelated to that that being to
the level of council tax
certainly
right we have started the vote i
remember happy first did you have
something you wanted to say before we
commence voting
your microphone is mute council dawson
still should i
sh um i'm just wondering at this point
um you know because i don't agree with
the parking i mean obviously i think
this should be struck at the moment from
the budget so i'd be forced into voting
against it
i think under the proviso that we have
dealt with that separately that there
will be changes after we were only
making recommendations but we must
recognize that our recommendations would
imply
changes whether what the level and
extent of those changes is
is is is not the point the point is that
we are saying that we don't entirely
agree with the original presentation for
the parking proposal that goes for all
of us so all it's doing is just covering
that because otherwise it doesn't make
sense i think you'd be you'd be quite
okay to vote for the budget on the sense
on that basis but the problem is that
when it goes to goes outside of um when
it goes outside or it's going to go to
cabinet
there is absolutely no representation
from the eastern part of the district so
i i just don't think this is hence
another reason for the comprehensive
parking review so i'm in a very
difficult position here because the
budget i quite agree with but it's
certainly not so i don't want to be
forced into voting for this budget you
have the option to abstain council
and that may be your best solution
if you think i'll fight against it not
abstain well okay you have that option
um but if if we have no counter proposal
and i i'm not sure i could well i don't
know we'd have to see
um council award you have your hand
raised or is that a legacy no
that is um uh it's a it's a point of
correction there um the eastern part of
the district is well represented on
cabinet by three members councillor
davis councillor busby and myself
uh
well i'd say two members
two yeah i think eight that's a matter
of three three out of three out of eight
representative
you know what i'm saying i think it's
very clear what i'm saying here you've
got five or six members that are awfully
sudbury frankly councillor dawson it's
not a matter for scrutiny no no i agree
i agree fair enough councillor grandin
okay please could you just um
um repeat again
the the
bit that you're excluding about parking
[Music]
with the exception of any effects made
by our recommendations on the parking
matter and bear in mind that we're
making this we voted on it and and it's
reasonable to hope that members would
support the decision of the committee um
obviously it's up to them individually
if they wish to do so but i think it's
just important that we include that
proviso since we have suggested changes
which would have an impact on the budget
but it's not a significant one but it is
it is a it is one but those changes we
don't agree with
but yes but uh it's perfectly reasonable
for you to support the collective
decision of the committee on which we
all serve um and that does not go
against anything else and you can make
your record you know your objections
known i think you really have done
already and i don't think anybody's
going to be in any doubt as to where you
or councillor grandin stand on this
so i would say off the cuff that you
have the perfect right to vote as you
wish and but you could support the
budget as well as as not uh it would not
be
a contradiction in terms
shall we carry out the vote then if that
can be started uh henrietta yeah chair
it has actually started already i'm
afraid and um council macro comes the
ground and still needs to vote yes i'm
just going in there now and council
dawson may i have your vote please i'm
against against
council grandin
are you having trouble voting or
it's not taking my confirmation
no i can't see
would you like to provide your vote um
to me
i i voted
you're abstain
so chair we have three roads four one
vote against and one abstention
okay so that's forwarded to cabinet for
noting obviously and
that would complete that matter i
believe
we now come to item 8 on the agenda bos
20 stroke 2 draft housing revenue
account hra
and the 2021 22 budget and four-year
outlook i'd like again to invite council
award the cabinet member for finance to
introduce this report bos 20 strokes 3.
thank you chairman i'm pleased to
introduce report bos 23 for the
2021-2022
hra budget and four-year outlook
it covers both the hra revenue account
and capital program
we have a sound 30-year business plan
which will support our ambitions to
increase our housing stock and which
continues to deliver favorable positions
for both revenue and capital
we have been helped by the ending of the
annual 1 rent reduction imposed by the
welfare reform and work act 2016.
the action now allows rents to be
increased by cpi plus one percent for
five years from 2020 to 2021. the
remaining 25 years of the business plan
are based on an annual rent increase of
cpi only
the business plan is attached to
appendix b and shows detail for years 1
to 10.
the new business plan will be presented
to cabinet and council during this year
as explained in paragraph 4.2 the plan
will include the need to invest in the
existing housing stock for environmental
improvements and safety enhancements and
to build new homes that meet the draft
design guide and an improved new build
specification
we are continuing with our aspiration to
increase our housing stock new homes of
all types provide us with new homes
bonus and council tax but additional
council housing also delivers rental
income and wider financial and social
benefits
curved 19 has had a major impact this
year construction was halted for a
period and property repairs and
maintenance were reduced to emergency
repairs only
however void work in order to support
the accommodation of the homeless and
rough sleepers continued
and the renovation of the lees in a
matter of days was an excellent example
of what we were still able to achieve
there is also no doubt that rent levels
are being impacted although in the first
half of the current financial year this
was minimal the full extent of this
won't be known for a while and so we
have assumed a 15 reduction for the
second half
a small amount of direct code related
costs has been incurred 47 000 pounds
for ppe but this has been covered by
from our government covered support
there has been no specific support for
the hra from government yet
the details of the budget are presented
in section 5 of the report table 1 and
paragraph 5.2 summarizing the key
elements and the movements from the 2020
to 2021 budget
a surplus position of 127 000 pounds is
forecast which is a reduction on the
2019 to 20 sorry in the 2020 2021
surplus we are proposing to transfer
this surplus to the strategic priorities
reserve
the budget has been based on a number of
assumptions the income ones that affect
our tenants being
a 1.5 rent increase which represents an
increase of 1.35 on the average weekly
rental of 91.70
garage rents will be unchanged there'll
be an increase of 69 pence per week for
sheltered housing charges
and utility charges will be unchanged
other movements are explained in
paragraph 5.5
the largest contribution to the reduced
surplus is the inclusion of 967 thousand
pounds for depreciation resulting from a
revaluation of the housing stock
also highlighted here are the key
achievements this year the most notable
being that voids remain at an average of
18 days and an excellent effort by
building services has resulted in the
work in progress reducing from 7500 to
1500 outstanding jobs
paragraphs 5.6 to 5.9 of the report show
the predicted movement in the reserves
the ambitious capital program will
require funding of 2.617 million pounds
from the strategic priorities reserve as
well as additional borrowing
the result will be a reduction in the
overall reserves balance to a still
healthy 13.167 million pounds
table three in section 5.10 of the
report
summarizes the capital expenditure and
financing for the next four years up to
2024 to 25 and appendix a provides more
detail
new bills and acquisitions are forecast
to be 24 million pounds including carry
forward from the current year
we have worked with successfully with an
ic need to identify sites
and they're now proposing an additional
161 affordable and 44 shared ownership
homes in the period 2021 to 24.
recently conduct field worsen has been
added to the sites list
finally i'd like to note that right to
buy sales have again shown a further
reduction and are lower than those
projected in the business plan
in 2019 to 2020 baba sold 11 against an
original projection of 20 sales
we have been delayed by covert in our
ability to use the right to buy receipts
before deadlines for returning unspent
portions to government however the
government has extended the deadline to
31st of march in recognition of this
we are looking at all opportunities to
acquire houses or land before this
deadline
and i also have
uh councillor channels one cabinet
member for housing and the assistant
director for housing governor gavin fist
both here to assist with answering any
housing related questions that you may
have
thank you chairman
thank you very much council award now i
think members can ask questions i'll ask
each member in turn if they have any
questions we'll start with councillor
adrian osborne at this point
uh thank you mr chairman you have no
questions at this time thank you
catherine grandin
thank you chair
um yes i do have a question um perhaps
it's something i should know already
could you remind me about
what we currently provide to sheltered
housing tenants
um i had thought that the majority
of the services that they used to
receive
are now
items that they
um purchase privately or pay for
separately now
um
during previous
as a result of previous changes to um
their service level so can you tell me
um what they now receive and what this
extra 69
pence per week it is therefore meant to
cover please
i think council osborne has the hand
raised i don't know if she wants to
answer that question
sorry council award i apologize but no
no no no
the castle was one of the hand raised
and also i think gavin could um provide
some further insight as well but we'll
go to council osborne first i think the
best yeah thank you mr chairman um yeah
thank you councillor grandin what
happened was as you know we had a review
of sheltered housing several years ago
and
we removed some of the sheltered housing
status in those complexes where we
removed it the occupants were given the
opportunity whether they wanted to
continue with having the provision of a
lot of an alarm and it was their choice
in those sites that have remained as um
with a sheltered criteria those services
continue so they have they don't have a
warden that lives on site but they do
have a manager that goes in obviously
not at the moment because we're
restricting that level of contact but
there is the availability for
those managers to go in each day and
also they have access to the alarm
system so as far as those sites that
remain sheltered
the the uh provision that they had
previously remains the same i don't know
if gavin wants to come in on that
anymore gavin
um yes thank you uh uh council osborne
and thank you uh chair for permitting me
to come in um i think uh councillor
osborne has summarized it really well
just to add uh to that obviously the
service charges can encompass the
physical building the attributes such as
the um provision of
health and safety
improvements to scheme the general
ambience the physical structures
in addition to the support and wrap
around service so obviously naturally
over the last
few months we've found that we've had to
offer a different offer
in terms of telephone uh servicing every
day rather than face to face uh but it's
to cover the the roles and
responsibilities of not only the scheme
manager or the housing manager but uh
other related housing staff um and
obviously the things like the warden
call system so if you imagine everything
uh wrapped up in in managing and
maintaining that building that's what's
included in those service charges i
should just add that we are expecting
and planning to conduct a review of
service charges um this year um and we
expect to bring that work back later to
cabinet later this year which will look
at some of the benefits or disbenefits
of pooling or depooling of service
charges
where we wrap all of the service charges
up across the whole service um or depool
it to individual schemes
so we expect to bring back the results
of that work later this year
um now just ask further um detail about
this please
um
so am i right in saying then that this
will apply this additional charge will
apply to
the
um group of um
housing or tenants who have remained in
a full
um
sheltered housing service that we now
offer
that's correct yes
yes so um those that were sheltered
were were
in
sheltered housing previously and their
um places became de-sheltered if that
sort of correct terminology
they won't be getting this extra charge
is that have i understood it correctly
yes that's correct council brandon thank
you very much
that would be approximately what 35
so pounds a year
at 69 p a week
and how many
how many um
tenants do we have in in this sector
please
uh off the top of my head councillor
grandin we have approximately
um it could be could be more than that
um but i'm happy to go away and provide
you with an overview of each site and
the numbers
in relation to each of those schemes but
this is revenue neutral is that correct
yes obviously the 69 pence
increase in service charges will pro
will mean that the service is cost
neutral um obviously any deficit would
require those in uh general needs uh
accommodation that are tenants of baby
mid-suffolk but do not receive the
benefits of the sheltered housing
service to to contribute so um our aim
is always to to ensure that those that
receive the benefit obviously uh
contribute and pay towards that i see
councillor osborne and raised so i just
wonder if she has anything to add
council to grandin
no thank you mr chairman i was just
going to um
exactly say what gavin has just said
thank you very much all right thank you
uh counselors really helpful answers
thank you very much
councillor dawson uh have you any
questions uh no she might have been
answered thank you thank you very much
uh council mclaren yes thank you chair
my questions are for gavin actually
um
this week i saw a national report about
the
um
thousands of council houses that are
empty at the moment
and the council thousands of garages
that are rented that not been used gavin
can you just give us an up-to-date
number at the moment that we've got in
baber please
uh thank you councillor mclaren for the
question i can't give you a specific
answer to that without going away and
checking the detail what i can do is
reassure you that
obviously in terms of garages yes we
will have um vacant garages we know that
demand is higher in some parts of our
district uh rather than than others and
where we've got
low demand we're obviously looking at a
range of options to increase
take up so that could be local promotion
it could be promoting the benefits of
having a garage or
a more strategic level looking at those
sites and making some decisions as to
what we do with those sites in the long
term in relation to housing we obviously
naturally have a churn of void homes
empty homes in any week
but they are typically being turned
around within the 18 days on average and
being re-let
where we might have a very very small
number of long-term empty homes uh where
we have um our plans to
regenerate or rejuvenate or build new
homes so i think of some some obvious
examples on the peninsula
near shotley and that brampton where
naturally where we've identified a site
to be redeveloped
we've left the housing uh temporarily
empty or long-term void in order to
facilitate those works um and and that's
probably as much as i can say but i'll
go away and just check the numbers on
the number of empty homes
two properties in branson sorry curry
council mclaren
i'm just going to put a point of
information i'm just going to add that
work has commenced on the former two
properties uh uh branson uh ready to
develop i think nine or so properties so
that's quite a useful um
recycling of housing stock with with
icini
right i've just got another question
kevin um
as rough sleepers are a group of people
very close to my heart
and i understand that ipswich
uh bera council
have provided pod pods for those rough
sleepers that don't necessarily want to
comply have we got any experience of
that in baber or has it not been an
issue at all
okay um thank you uh council mclaren for
the question um obviously um the
management of homelessness and temporary
housing and the management of rough
sleeping is a general fund function and
sits outside of the housing revenue
account hence why you won't see
uh any uh figures or information about
that within this report what i can do is
reassure you that since the government's
original everyone in ask
which was around uh march april last
year uh baber has been making every
tireless effort to ensure that rough
sleepers are offered uh temporary
accommodation uh to protect them from um
obviously uh covered and we have a
number of those placements um in
temporary accommodation
typically the temporary accommodation
that we are using in baba is either our
own accommodation um so that could be
sites such as at santa room court in
sudbury
or the lees that was mentioned
in council awards introduction
as well as
potentially bed and breakfast or hotel
accommodation depending on the numbers
requiring it and i can confirm that we
have got a number of rough sleepers in
in those types of accommodation both
from the original everyone in um and
subsequent asks of government to get
ross leapers
off the streets um we did consider as
part of our response to covid um
cabins uh and and they wouldn't be
dissimilar to what you uh refer to in
terms of of the port cabin style i know
in west suffolk they chose that option
rather than the use of hotels um and and
they've worked uh really well for us we
made a a conscious decision based on a
business case and and actually uh we
could evidence that hotel accommodation
was going to be uh both uh more cost
effective and more flexible for us um
but the use of um
cabin style accommodation whether it be
for short-term or longer-term placements
for those that are in required temporary
accommodation is something that we're
considering
more than two-thirds of those that we
are currently housing
in temper accommodation require one bed
need
we have a very small supply of one bed
accommodation um in our district and
therefore we need to look at alternative
options to provide them
with perhaps short to medium-term
housing so
in that that sense cabins are being
considered at this stage yes okay thank
you very much gavin thank you
note councillor osborne has her hand
raised she may have something to say at
this point
yeah thank you mr chairman it's actually
to rewind back to council mclaren's uh
question on empty properties there may
sometimes happen a property becomes
empty when a
resident has gone into care and that
property has to remain
um empty until that resident
advises us that they're going into
permanent care rather than just
temporary care so sometimes
i get contacted by counsellors because i
have a question on this if you see a
property that's empty that could
sometimes be the case that person's gone
into care
we they keep remain that tenancy
agreement until
such time as it's um we're notified that
they've gone into permanent care
thank you mr chairman thank you thank
you sadly these days some of them may
have gone into hospital
um i have one question um i'd just like
to ask and it's a concerning
recommendation 3.2
we're increasing uh council house rents
by
1.5
percent can i ask when the last time we
increased council house rents was
and by how much
chair if i can if i can come in um we
did increase uh council house rents last
year uh which was the first year of the
new uh government rent standard so um
rents increased last year by
exactly the same formula but it would
have been a slightly different amount um
based on what cpi was in september
prior to that there was a restriction on
increases in council house rents was
there not
that's correct
for for a period of five years
we would we were obliged to do what
so during that period we were obliged to
reduce rents um i don't have the the
figures in in front of me um but when uh
mid suffolk debated this item last week
they compared and contrast um figures
for rents in 2015 16 versus what rents
will be in
2122 and and on average they were only
approximately 11 pence uh higher now
than they were um more than six years
ago but i don't have the figures to hand
for babe i'm happy to go away and check
no thank you i just wanted to establish
the point
okay um i noticed we have other members
present today um if there are no
no more questions from committee members
i'd like to invite any other members of
the council presents today if they would
like to ask any questions and i see
councillor ayers hand raised councillors
thank you very much chair um i'd just
like to check we had um a suppertown
council meeting and um the repairs and
the money that's being spent in us at
minton road area and our police
inspectors said it's a complete waste of
money because it's just going to be as
bad again i'd like to raise that thank
you
okay thank you for your comment
councillor osborne
yes if i could just come in on that one
that originally that that money has been
ring fenced
for those repairs to minded and
cavendish for quite a few years now and
it was actually in negotiation with the
police that we um decided that it was
now time to undertake these repairs and
inspector kevin horton has been very
very much on board very much involved in
the discussions of what should be done
what shouldn't be done
and he's very much signed up to it and
has actually been chasing us to get
these repairs done so i'm not quite sure
where councillor ayers gets this
information from because it's different
to what uh we're being told at baber
thank you mr chairman um can i come back
there yes
i thought councillor osmond was actually
at that pre-town council meeting where
actually inspector kevin horton told us
that it was a waste of money thank you
perhaps that can be answered um outside
this meeting then thank you
gavin you have something to add to this
thank you chair i did want to uh just
just add and and respond to councilors
um there's a million pound improvements
um being invested in in midtown
cavendish uh way for members that are
not aware they are um three-story uh
flats uh as you uh in the sudbury town
center from uh from from the direction
um
and um in fact those improvements will
go a long way to um improving both fire
safety and security in relation to door
entry and secure
design as well as environmental
improvements we know that through
consultation because actually we have
leaseholders on that side
that the improvements have been well
received and probably long overdue um i
know that there has been um some
anti-social behavior within the area
and i know we've been working uh really
closely with the police to try and
resolve uh some of that some of which
originates from that specific uh aerial
location and i know the police have been
very positive in uh recent days and
weeks
of the work uh between both baber uh
district council and the police uh
working um in partnership uh to to
respond and and deal with some of these
behaviors and i believe that the
improvements will go a long way to
supporting that further
thank you very much kevin
uh any other questions from members
could you use the raise hand function
councillor grandin
thank you um i don't know if this is a
relevant question or not
but
um can you tell me whether it's been
looked into whether any of our
properties have the cladding
issues that's currently in the news
please
uh chair if i could take that question
um we are
we are um fortunate that we don't have
uh accommodation uh such as those
identified uh elsewhere uh nationally uh
with cladding um we also are possibly
fortunate that we don't have the the
significant high rise that obviously uh
inner cities have uh we have conducted a
review of our sites um and i'm pleased
to say that we don't have any of the
combustible material that um is having
to be removed from other tower blocks
thank you very much i think that's quite
useful also for it to be in this public
forum
where it's announced thank you
reassurance
uh any other questions from members
before we open this item up for debate
in that case i'll open the item up for
debate
i have an order of debate but i can be
changed starting with councillor mclaren
don't have anything at the moment to say
chairman thank you everyone councillor
osborne
thank you uh thank you mr chairman yeah
i have nothing really to add to a debate
but i would like to once again
congratulate
gavin and
heather and the rest of the housing team
they've done immaculate work all the way
through every year that i've been
associated with the council and i can
only express my
delight and i'm grateful thanks for what
they've done i think they've
brought the housing issues uh
to baber
and resolved
of very much uh a great deal of of
problems thank you
thank you councillor grandin
no i'm quite happy thank you okay
councillor dawson
uh now i'm quite happy and i just say
thank you very much after
five years i think we're well on our way
to getting angel court completed
yeah
yes
i'd add to that that it's it's some
projects that you've seen developing
over a period of years coming to
fruition and of course you have to you
realize that it does sometimes take
those years to get everything lined up
and and to have all the necessary
partners involved but so we seem to be
making headway um on a steady basis and
obviously we'd only want to see that
continue
um if there are no further uh debate
points uh perhaps we should move to
recommendations
now we have some recommendations
presented to us in the report
for which we'll be going to cabinet they
are run 3.1 to 3.6
over to you members
does anybody have any
recommendations
sorry councillor brandon
i'm happy to support the recommendations
okay and proposing those i would thank
you
that's 3.1 through 3.6 uh do you have a
do we have a seconder for that i'll
second it thank you councillor dawson
um
yeah all i would say is it's um
it's all
quite reasonable stuff um there are
small changes
relatively speaking fairly neutral
in which case we've got the
recommendations as recommended in the
report unless there are any other
proposals for recommendations
i'll ask the governance officers to
prepare those um on modern gov ready for
voting and then we'll commence with the
vote
uh well chair we will be uh that the ovu
and scrutiny committee um support
recommendations 3.1 to 3.7 in the report
to cabinet i have three point six in
there oh this is three point six oh
you're right there's actually no it says
three point seven i have two separate
things
i have to know it's okay it's my fault
it's in my script and the script is
wrong i do apologize it's entirely down
to me
so 3.1 through 3.7
um
the vote is ready to take is it yeah
i've started the vote remember
go to moderngov
now highlighted in blue
we have one member who's not voted yet
yes i know
i'm sorry sorry
cancer dawson may i may i take your vote
in the meantime four
four
so chair that is complete now and that
is five votes for chair
that's carried unanimously thank you
very much members
uh we're drawing towards the close
but we still have
some further business to deal with
which is the forthcoming decision list
and do members have any comments on the
forthcoming decision list
in that case we shall move on it is just
for noting and of course it's available
on a weekly basis in
a regular link that should be sent to
all members
uh
item 10 the baber overview and scrutiny
work plans
uh these are mostly going to be in
conjunction with mid suffolk but you can
see in item 10 the proposed
current work plan
does anybody have any comments if you
could raise use the raised hand function
no i see none
that is for noting as well and uh
fundamentally that concludes this
meeting
oh
um
i don't know whether this is appropriate
to raise or not so i'm sure you'll
correct me or something ahead correct if
it affects the work plan it's what it's
like that's what it's there for okay
thank you
um
there's been a lot of concern in in
the sudbury community
about bellevue house and the
um
the access point
are these
items that we should consider bringing
to ons and are they appropriate well
that's a very good question i'm glad you
asked it um it has been under
consideration and i've obviously checked
through with the uh officers and also
with my own understanding of the
constitution
the first thing is that uh the access
point
as i understand it
is a matter of a um
what's the expression i'm looking for
a delegated decision on an operational
matter effectively what is happening
there is that a contract that the
council have held with sudbury town
council has come or is coming to a close
uh proposals are being prepared
for an alternative provision
of the access point not advice center it
is an access point as it always was
that
preparation has not been completed yet
no proposals have been made so scrutiny
cannot really uh it would be in draft
form and we're not entitled to
scrutinize something that's in draft
form until there is a report
we cannot scrutinize something and in
this instance as it's an operational
matter
it is not necessarily something we can
scrutinize
there are other avenues for members with
concerns to raise matters
uh but they would need to check the
rules on uh councillor call for action i
suspect in this instance i'm not
convinced i'm not absolutely certain of
that but that's what my current reading
of the situation seems to indicate
the second one
would be on uh proposals for bellevue
house and again here bellevue house has
not actually had any decision made it
has just been put out for tender
inviting people to make proposals for
what could be done with bellevue house
without those proposals being available
to compare
again
it's not possible to scrutinize
something which does not yet exist in
terms of a report
again a counsellor call for action is a
possibility um but again it castler call
for action requires the members
concerned
to have exhausted every other avenue
that is available to them and there may
be still some avenues to exhaust if you
follow me
so as of now
as i see it at the moment and the advice
i've received and my own study indicates
that
we can't or won't be able to call those
to scrutiny simply is not within our
powers
i hope that at least addresses your
question if not satisfies you with the
answer
yes i mean i i feel um
that it's a bit unfortunate for sudbury
members because i um but if if those are
the rules those are the rules well i can
suggest that they examine the
um possibilities contained within the
ccfa council a call for action within
the constitution
um
basically the constitution is the rules
we operate under it's effectively
a part of our legal framework of course
um and obviously that's become a matter
of some interest recently
thank you uh anyway that that i hope
answers your question yes uh that should
conclude this meeting thank you very
much members for your attention to
detail and i know it's been a lengthy
meeting but i think it was worth
carrying out um regardless of any
disagreements i think actually the
fundamental principle
that the parking plan should change has
been made the relevant point being
how much
and when
uh that concludes this meeting the next
joint overview and scrutiny committee
meeting will be on the monday the 15th
of february
at one o'clock p.m not our normal 9 30
starting time
okay so please take that note thank you
very much the meeting will now close
you